Guten Morgen Linus.
Morgen, Tim.
Sollen wir sagen, wie spitz ist?
Viertel vor zwölf.
Okay.
Ja und es ist wahr geworden äh die neunundfünfzigste Ausgabe von Lokbuch Netzpolitik äh erblickt das Licht des Tages. Äh wir waren ein wenig äh im Urlaub und in der Diaspora und äh bedrückt und lagen unterm Tisch, oder?
Weiß nicht, was hast du denn gemacht?
Äh dazu kommen wir später.
Ach so, ja okay, also aber ich habe mir so ein bisschen den Lenz äh äh gemacht und dachte mir schon, ich werde schon nichts verpassen. Aber es kann schon passieren in einer Woche. Ja und das ähm,
Naja, war ja nicht ganz, war ja nicht ganz Kollateralschaden äh äh frei. Die letzte Zeit und jetzt müssen wir das hier alles wieder aufrollen.
Es war eine eine schwarze Woche in der Netzpolitik und äh da braucht man natürlich auch dann seelischen Beistand und sowas aufzuarbeiten.
Deswegen haben wir einen Gast, der immer sehr positives Weltbild bekannt ist.
Bekannt ist.
Ausgerechnet in der dunkelsten Woche des Jahres.
Genau, wir sagen hallo zu Frank, Frank Rieger, guten Tag, willkommen bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik. Äh,
Die Geschichte wiederholt sich, äh Frank habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, äh vor vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren hatten wir ja auch mal so die große Hackerdepression und dann bist du ja mit Rock mal äh auf den Altar geschlichen und hast äh sozusagen das Ende der Welt verkündet,
äh äh ja, er hat recht, aber es hat halt sozusagen auch einen interessanten Defekt gehabt, äh nämlich, dass dann sozusagen genau,
mehr oder weniger im Anschluss so eine der erfolgreichsten Aktionen dieser Gemeinde dann wiederum sich manifestierte die es bis dahin gab und damit hat sich das dann eigentlich,
umgekehrt oder ist das jetzt eine zu optimistische Sicht?
Nachher kurzfristig ist die Sicht sicherlich richtig, aber langfristig ist, glaube ich, irgendwie doch schon alles ganz schön im Eimer.
Und äh also was wir jetzt irgendwie so letzte Woche hatten, war eigentlich mehr oder minder der Ausblick auf darauf, äh was jetzt so kommt. Äh,
Weil wir äh ja Netzpolitik jedoch eigentlich immer bisher so die letzten drei Jahre so ein Feld von Optimismus und Lebensfreude und wir kriegen da was bewegt ist,
und ähm so, was wir jetzt da so gesehen haben, ist, dass es einfach der Regierung mittlerweile einigermaßen egal ist. So, weil äh sie haben halt nichts mehr zu befürchten.
Also alle Hüte raus aus dem Schrank, schön zuziehen.
Na ja, das würde ich so nicht sagen, da kommen wir vielleicht später noch dazu, was wir genauer machen sollten, aber klar ist jedenfalls, dass die diese optimistischen,
Ansichten von wegen, wir müssen das denen alles nur richtig erklären und dann wenn ich es schon verstehen und dann kommen die schon irgendwie auf die richtigen Gedanken äh und dann werden die halt auch schon verstehen, dass unsere Lösung und unsere Ansichten die besseren sind, dass das äh
nicht also wirklich nur für einen kleinen Teil gerade der Politik zu traf und wer halt äh doch einen,
relativ großen Teil von Politik haben, die mittlerweile verstanden hat und die halt einfach Scheiße und bösartig ist. Äh und das jetzt halt auch in Netzpolitikfeld raushängen lässt.
Äh ich würde sagen, schauen wir mal, was eigentlich äh äh passiert ist. Äh heben heben wir die Scherben mal auf. Womit geht's los?
Leistungsschutzrecht.
Oh, unser Klassiker.
Ich hatte das ja, wir hatten das ja eigentlich vorhergesagt, dass es ungefähr so passieren würde, wie es dann auch passiert ist. Ich ich rühme jetzt mal auch hier unsere äh Weitsichtigkeit im im Rahmen dieser.
Immer noch die Wette laufen, dass es am Ende doch noch irgendwo dran scheitert, aber.
Woran äh woran klammerst du deine Hoffnung jetzt, dass äh Bundesverfassungsgericht? Ein ein.
Gericht, also ich könnte mir halt sehr gut vorstellen, dass das äh daran irgendwie dann nochmal zerschellt, aber ich bin jetzt auch nicht unbedingt total überrascht, dass das jetzt äh erstmal beschlossen wurde. Denn das wurde es in unserem Bundestag.
Ja, das hatten wir ja, glaube ich, schon erledigt. Also das das war, glaube ich, schon Thema der Sendung. Das Problem war jetzt, dass er die Hoffnung bestand, dass der Bundesrat sich drum kümmert,
Und äh die Hoffnung war, dass der äh der Bundesrat den Vermittlungsausschuss anruft und da irgendwie so lange rum blockiert
bis es Neuwahlen gibt und dann mit Hilfe des Prinzips die ganze Nummer vom Tisch ist, das wäre eine ähm,
Wäre, sage ich mal, äh irgendwie im Rahmen des Möglichen gewesen, wenn sie's geschafft hätten, das ausreichend zu verschleppen.
Also zu Philipp aber das ging nicht, weil wir festgestellt haben, die SPD hat auch Angst vor Axel Springer.
Ja, die.
Wo die korrekte Zusammenfassung hier.
SPD hat auch Angst vor Achselspringer.
Und vor der WAZ, im Speziellen, weil wer war es, der jetzt konkret äh abgelehnt hat? Das war NRW. Also die Länder.
War der Landesverband von Pierr Steinbrück? Also es war halt Steinbrücks eigener Landesverband, aus dem er kommt, ähm.
Okay so kann man's natürlich auch noch sehen, ja?
Äh ist aus meiner Sicht war es eine rein Wahlkampftaktische Aktion. Sie haben halt irgendwie
Lippenbekenntnis so finden wir eigentlich scheiße gemacht und haben dann aber gesagt äh wir werden's jetzt aber nicht abschaffen, weil tja so, also ohne irgendeine irgendeinen tatsächlichen Grund
Also sie haben ja genau das, was sie hätten, tun sollen beim Leistungsschutzrecht,
haben sie ja bei anderen Gesetzesvorhaben der Bundesregierung genau getan, dass sie sich nämlich im Bundesrat haben auflaufen lassen, das heißt also die sagen wir die Mechanik der Macht hätte schon funktioniert, wenn sie es denn gewollt hätten äh aber ganz klar war, sie wollten halt nicht, weil sie wollten sich heute jetzt nicht irgendwie,
Monat vor dem aktuellen, heißen Wahlkampf mit Springer anlegen.
Ja, das Ganze kurz nach der neu ähm,
nennt man das, Neubildung des Bundesrats nach der Niedersachsenwahl, der eigentlich erstmalig auch die äh Mehrheiten so gelegt hat, dass das eben auch durchaus realistisch gewesen wäre, da äh etwas zu machen.
Es gibt dann die Begründung von Per Steinbock, der sagt, dass äh ja, wir haben ja klar, natürlich haben wir die ganze Zeit gesagt, das Leistungsschutzricht ist, es ist Quatsch. Ähm aber wir wollen jetzt nicht auf Basis eines Vorschlags diskutieren, den wir sowieso ablehnen,
und ähm er hat also quasi diese in seiner Argumentation Klammer, der so diese Option aus, als gäbe es die nicht und sagt ja, selbst wenn wir das jetzt im Vermittlungsausschuss getragen hätten, dann wär's ja doch wieder zurück in den Bundestag gegangen,
Und äh da entsprechend ähm hätte dann wieder schwarz gelb machen können, was sie wollen. Deswegen wollen wir jetzt lieber gewählt werden und ein besseres Leistungsschutzrecht machen.
Das ist gut, ne?
Vor allen Dingen und genau, genau das haben sie beim Betreuungsrecht haben sie äh beim Betreuungsgeld haben sie genau das getan, ne? Also genau da haben sie
genau diese Mechanik angewendet, dass sie gesagt haben, so okay, wir verschleppen's halt mal eine Runde in den in den Bundesrat, damit's halt nicht mehr vor den Wahlen irgendwie äh zum Beschluss kommt und dann ist sowieso ein neues Spiel
ob da ein neues Spiel ist, ist einmal dahin gestellt, also momentan sieht's ja nach den Umfragen aus, als wenn's genauso weitergeht, wie bisher.
Was jetzt mit dem Betreuungsgeld oder mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht.
Damit der politischen Situation in Deutschland ja so also ich meine ist halt.
Ach so, ja, ja. Gut, da ja äh verstehe ich.
Äh also wenn insbesondere irgendwie Herr Steinbrück, der tut ja alles dafür, dass es halt irgendwie äh sicherlich keinen Machtwechsel geben wird. Und insofern ist das Ganze halt einfach auch eher so ein na ja, so nur so ein Spiel, ne.
Letztendlich.
Denn jetzt überhaupt Neues zum Leistungsschutzrecht? Also hat sich denn da jetzt äh in irgendeiner Form nach der Beschlussfassung noch irgendwas ergeben?
Das hat sich auf der praktischen Seite was ergeben, dass halt eine Menge Verlage gesagt haben, wir sie wollen's nicht nicht anwenden. Also sie haben da keine Lust drauf. Äh sie wollen's halt nicht äh.
Eine Menge, also heiße weiß ich.
Äh Heise ähm, wer war's noch, glaube ich, Süddeutsche? Wollte, wollte er auch.
Freitag, ich glaube, der Freitag hat sich auch dagegen ausgesprochen. Die Süddeutsche auch.
Ich glaube, die wollte oder die weiß nicht mehr genau, ob sie's schon haben, nachgucken.
Ich dachte, die Süddeutsche hat das äh war die nicht auch so ein bisschen auf der Fahnenwedel.
Was man halt verstehen muss, ist, dass die ähm diese Leistungsschutzrecht hat da äh in ihrer ganzen deutschen Presselandschaft gerade bei den großen Verlagen zu intensiven Konflikten zwischen Redaktion und Verlag geführt,
Also die Verlage waren erstmal alle dafür, weil alles, was nach mehr Geldrichter, sind sie halt prinzipiell dafür, ohne genau zu verstehen, dass sich Dach verspringen, das Kragen spannen lassen,
Ähm und äh die Redaktionen waren bis auf relativ wenige Ausreißer eigentlich ziemlich unisone dagegen, äh weil sie gesagt haben, so, das äh ist halt zum einen das ein Springergesetz, wo wir uns deshalb,
mit unserem Namen vor den Kahn sparen lassen äh und zum anderen äh führte halt dazu, dass es halt ein Risiko gibt für die,
ja quasi die journalistische Freiheit und irgendwie den ja Dinge von anderen zu verwenden, was ja doch ein guter Teil des deutschen Journalismus ausmacht und deswegen,
Ähm ist das halt innerhalb der der also der Verlagsredaktionsbeziehung auch nicht immer so äh so ganz freundschaftlich gewesen, sondern jetzt nachdem halt äh ja dieser Kompromiss, dieser sogenannte äh passiert ist, also dass halt die,
nun wieder doch legal sein sollen also ohne,
Geld verwendbar sein sollen. Äh uns halt eben auch noch darum ging, dass die das Gesetz so unscharf ist, dass klar ist, dass jeder Verlag, der es anwenden will, erstmal drei Jahre vor Gericht ziehen muss,
ähm sind die Verlage halt auch eben nicht mehr so.
Warum müssen die fürs Gesicht.
Ne, weil die Formulierung im Gesetz in dem Gesetz, wie es jetzt durchgegangen ist, sind halt so unscharf,
wo auch die Regierung sagt, ja das überlassen wir den Gerichten zu definieren, was die Länge des verwendbaren Ausschnitts ist,
so so schwammig, dass jeder Verlag, der sagt, okay, jetzt will ich aber Geld von dir haben äh und der tut es gegen irgendjemand, der auch nur ansatzweise irgendwie Support oder Community oder Geld hat, äh der wird halt vor Gericht gehen, sondern dann fechten wir es halt mal aus.
Na gut, ich meine, ein River wird das sicher sich äh nicht machen, weil die nah einfach aus den finanziellen äh äh Konsequenzen, die sich daraus ergeben.
Die Communitys, die also klar sollte, sollte es nicht ein River machen, aber ähm ich sage mal für so was halten irgendwie die zwanzig, fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro, die man dafür braucht, zusammenzukriegen, ist jetzt auch kein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Ne, also das ist halt irgendwie so ein.
Gut, aber es ist ja mehr als nur das Geld, das ist ja auch einfach eine Menge.
Eine Menge Arbeit. Du musst das halt.
Und dann hast du auch echt nichts anderes mehr zu tun, also ich.
Klar ist auf jeden Fall, dass dass also was jetzt so häufiger durch die Gegend geisterte, das hat man jetzt halt,
bestimmte Blogs oder irgendwie bestimmte Formen von Aggregationen wie Rivers macht halt eben nicht mehr machen kann und dass man deswegen halt irgendwie äh aufhört damit. Äh das halte ich halt ganz ehrlich gesagt für Unsinn. Also man sollte sich da halt einfach nicht ins Boxhauen jagen lassen,
und wenn die ersten Klagen kommen, dann ist auch ganz klar, dass wenn man halt einfach zu Google geht und da sagt er, Alter, hier,
ihr habt das Geld auch in eurem Interesse, also tut mal was dazu. So, also es ist halt, denke ich mal, einen.
Auch interessanter Ansatz.
Die Schlacht geht jetzt heute vor den Gerichten weiter, wenn jetzt nicht noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, äh aus bürokratischen Gründen, Papier im Bundesrat alles und sie ist nicht verabschiedet bekommen. Ähm,
Aber klar ist halt, wir müssen äh das wird halt vor die Gerichte gehen. Ähm ein interessanter Punkt, den ich aber nochmal ansprechen wollte an der Stelle ist, warum ist denn das eigentlich so passiert und warum ist denn, weil wir ja gerade eigentlich ja sozusagen über Netzpolitik reden,
warum interessiert diese Leistungsschutzrecht eigentlich niemanden außer einer relativ kleinen Gruppe Leute.
Also du meinst eine Bevölkerung.
Genau, also warum gab's halt warum es sozusagen nicht möglich gewesen halt dafür eine eine Mobilisierung, die halt irgendwie anderen als politischen Themen adäquat ist, indem man Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder ähm daraus halt eben so eine Mobilisierung zu schlagen und der Grund ist halt einfach, dass es den Leuten einigermaßen egal ist,
Leute die fühlen sich,
ich find's persönlich betroffen von der Vorortsdatenspeicherung, die fühlen sich persönlich betroffen von Netzzensur, das sind alle Sachen, die greifbar sind, aber so ein irgend so 'n Blog soll dann halt mal vielleicht für so 'n Zitat Geld zahlen müssen? Hä?
Klar, es betrifft die halt nicht und vor allem was natürlich auch, was auch vollkommen nachvollziehbar ist
niemand begreift jetzt, ähm so wie das eben sagen wir mal im Netzkreisen verstanden wird, so diese Konsequenzen, die sich daraus eben.
Ergeben könnten.
Geben könnten für Startups et cetera, wirtschaftliche Entwicklung. Das ist halt auch ein Meta-Thema. Und von daher ist es eigentlich auch etwas, was,
Klassisch in der Politik TM äh.
Verhandelt werden sollte, ja.
Korrekt verstanden werden sollte und genau das findet eben so nicht statt.
Ne, und der Punkt ist halt, was wir halt an diesem Leistungsschutzrecht gesehen haben, ist, dass die äh der Wille der Politik,
zu handeln auf der Basis von konkreten,
also wie sie zum Beispiel auch in den Anhörungen herkamen, gering ist,
Insbesondere wenn halt groß politische Interessen, wie zum Beispiel irgendwie die Hose voll haben vor Springer dagegen stehen.
also wir sind halt nicht an den Punkten mehr, dass die das nicht verstehen. Also die Abgeordneten haben das ganz genau verstanden,
Aber den ging halt einfach irgendwie, also deren Interesse, ob jetzt so ein paar Blogs oder Aggregatoren zumachen oder halt noch irgend so ein Hippes Web Startup mit runden Ecken und irgendwie neue revolutionäre Präsentation von News und nicht mehr existieren kann.
Oder ob ihnen Springer den Wahlkampf verhagelt.
Sind halt vollständig andere Prioritäten so, ne? Und deswegen,
müssen wir uns halt also dieses Leistungsschutzrecht lehrt uns zwei Dinge. Zum einen ähm ist es nicht möglich eine große Mobilisierung zu machen mit Themen, die halt zu Meta sind, die halt zu wenig Leute an äh angehen und wenn wir so tun, als könnten wir so eine Mobilisierung für solche Themen leisten.
Aber bei AXA war es ja auch sehr mieter.
Nee, ActA war eben nicht im Meter, weil man da konkrete Beispiele aufmachen konnte, dass es Leuten an den äh tatsächlich an ihre Lebensführung geht,
Ne, weil sie immer klar dein iPod wird an der Grenze kontrolliert. Hat jeder sofort eine Vorstellung davon. Es ist vollkommen klar. Betrifft jeden.
du kannst plötzlich keine digitale Musik mehr über die Grenzen mitnehmen oder sie können da dein Notbook kontrollieren. Kann sich jeder vorstellen.
Aber es war ja nicht unbedingt jetzt ein Argument, was so im Mittelpunkt stand.
Deshalb für viele Leute, für viele Leute war das so ein so ein ganz greifbares Ding, auch wenn's nur so halb wahr war.
Ich hatte mir so die Eindrücke, es ging mir so über dieses Falscheing, aber ich stimme dir zu, das ist das Eso oder.
Genau selber. Betrifft halt Millionen von Leuten und nicht halt so ein paar Blogs, ne? Und also das hat, glaube ich, so einen Punkt, den wir, den wir uns tatsächlich irgendwie ins Notizbuch ins Lockbuch schreiben sollten, ist, dass äh nicht so tun sollten, als das Politik,
Gemeinde oder wie auch immer man's nennen mag, dass wir Themen, die ganz klar kein Massenpotential haben, so hoch hängen,
dass alle erwarten, okay, da muss es jetzt wieder so eine Bewegung wie bei Acta geben,
Wenn's die nicht gibt, na dann ist es den Leuten im Zweifel egal, dann kann man's halt durchdrücken, sondern muss halt klar machen, okay, das sind Bücher, solche Themen wie wie Leistungsschutzrecht sind halt Nischenthemen, die halt nicht,
Millionen von Menschen angehen und wo halt dementsprechend halt einfach die Strategie eine andere sein muss, man eben nicht versucht, irgendwie aller Google dann halt irgendwie mit Videos da halt irgendwie eine relativ durchsichtige, eigennützige Mobilisierung zu machen, sondern halt einfach klar sagt, okay, das ist ein Lobby-Thema,
Und da muss man halt anders agieren und andere Strategien anwenden.
So haben ja äh also durchaus einige sich
anfangs verhalten, also einigen, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, die also sagten, ja, Leistungsschutzrecht äh schwierig, weil da kämpften irgendwie zwei Lobbyarmeen gegeneinander und letztendlich sind wir hier nur die
Innocents, die eventuell mitunter die Räder kommen, aber so wirklich eine eine Leidenschaft haben wir dann nicht,
hatte ich persönlich jetzt beim Leistungsschutzrecht auch nicht, weil's jetzt bei einigen anders war. Aber.
Also mir ging's halt auch so. Also für mich war das halt so ein jetzt auch noch dritte Thema halt.
War halt so, man konnte sich da eher zurücklehnen und sich an den Kopf fassen und relativ viel Blödsinn hören. Vielleicht wäre das auch eine eine sinnvollere Strategie gewesen, dass äh,
du hast halt gerade gesagt, wenn man viel Energie in ein in ein Thema wirft, was den Leuten egal ist und
Ich weiß halt nicht, wer hat denn da viel Energie reingeworfen? Ja, Google mit seiner Igelsache, ja, klar. Andererseits geht's ja jetzt auch Stimmen, die sagen, und die finde ich eigentlich auch das Argument finde ich durchaus auch ähm,
sollte berücksichtigt werden. Die sagen, was haben denn die Verlage TM, beziehungsweise was hat Springer denn jetzt da für ein Gesetz? Okay, die haben eine
maximale Rechtsunsicherheit, aber die können sich mit dem Gesetz, was da jetzt verabschieden wurde, auch nicht irgendwie hinsetzen und ähm äh mit Sekt anstoßen und Jahresbohnen hier ausschütten, weil,
Also solange da irgendwie diese Textausschnitte nicht definiert sind und so ist das für die auch jetzt nur ein Etappensieg, aber nicht äh.
Gut, da hatten wir ja eine These, da würde mich auch mal interessieren, was Frank da von äh hält, nämlich das ist vielleicht erst äh für Springer gar nicht erst mal so wichtig ist,
genau in diesem Gesetz drin steht, sondern dass für sie vor allem wichtig ist, dass es das gibt,
Vehikel ist, das ist einerseits gezeigt hat, wir können das.
Eine Machtdemonstration.
Einfach eine Machtdemonstration, aber eben auch ein jetzt ist es da und etwas ändern ist immer was anderes als es erstmalig beschließen.
Also auf der strategischen Ebene ist es für Springer einen also ging's für Springer darum, halt einen äh sage ich mal, einen mindestens einen Etappensieg gegen Google,
zu erringen. Also so ist das für die, glaube ich, intern, dass die äh versuchen, dieses Paradigma Newses Free zu brechen.
Und also der Springer ist ja auch ganz weit vorne mit Payballs, die sind ja die ersten, die in Deutschland halt irgendwie vier Tageszeitungen, Payball Experimente im großen Stil machen,
Gerüchten zufolge wird's da auch noch mehr geben, also die werden halt da, also da auf Media war da neulich dieser Artikel darüber, dass die halt einen ähm so eine flächendeckende Springerpay mit irgendwie an einer Stelle einzahlen und dann alle Springerzeitungen lesen können,
ähm geplant, wo sich halt irgendwie da in Osteuropa so eine Firma gekauft haben, die Technologie dafür baut. Und so, also die wollen also denen ist halt,
klar, dass die ähm die wollen halt Geld verdienen und zwar viel Geld verdienen mit äh mit ihren Zeitungen und ihren sonstigen Medienaktivitäten. Und.
Für die ist das halt so ein Ding, die wollen am Ende Geld aus dem Google Top haben. Das ist halt das Ziel. Google verdient Geld im Internet. Die deutschen Verlage verziehen gerade kein Geld im Internet,
jedenfalls nicht so viel und ähm,
irgendwie ihre bei Google auftauchen, wollen sie halt irgendwie ran an diesen Topf. Das ist halt der, der eigentliche Hintergrund von diesem, von diesem ganzen Gesetz.
dass es nun nicht passiert, also dass dieses Ziel nicht erreicht wird, ist halt für die, sage mal, die anderen Verlage, die da mitgespielt haben, viel bitterer als für Springer, weil für Springer ist das immer noch die Machtdemonstration und halt das Brechen dieses Newsletters.
Wenn,
Also es gibt ja immer noch den, den anderen Punkt, da waren wir uns hier auch uneinig. Ich ich glaube ja, dass sollte Google nun sagen, alles klar, Springer oder jeder, der irgendwie sich zum Leistungsschutzrecht bekennt, äh fliegt aus Google News raus
Dann würden sie ja, und das hatte äh Keße ja auch angekündigt, dann würden sie den über Kartell,
kommen, ne? Und sagen, ey, äh ihr dürft uns nicht ausschließen. Was ich trotzdem glaube, ist ja dieses Kräftegleich
oder dieses Kräftegleichgewicht,
wie das, dass das Leistungsschutzrecht jetzt herstellt. Das gilt ja erstmal nur für die Riesen, also für Springer gegenüber Google. Bei weitem aber nicht für die kleinen Verlage,
ähm,
Insofern hat natürlich auch ein verhältnismäßig kleiner Verlag wie Heise, äh ich meine, das kostet Ihnen ein müdes Arschrund, zu sagen, das machen wir nicht. Ist auch ganz klar, weil es für die tatsächlich das ähm.
Ja, die können es nicht tun, ja, das stimmt nicht.
Können's überhaupt nicht machen, ja? Ähm wenn Springer das macht, ja, dann wird das auf jeden Fall spannend. Die haben halt die können halt was äh dem gegenüber in die Waagschale werfen, ne.
Meine gute, also die Option für Google sind halt äh ist halt klar, die werden halt einen äh so weitermachen wie bisher. Äh das heißt also auf Google News irgendwie keine Werbung schalten,
ähm wenn die clever werden, könnten sie auch sowas machen, dass wenn halt äh äh eine Suchergebnis äh News Resultate enthält, dass sie dann einfach schlicht keine Werbung einblenden,
wir verdienen kein Geld mit einem Inhalten, schönen Tag noch,
und also sie hört sozusagen nicht nicht komplett aus dem Index, sondern halt nur selektiv dafür sorgen, dass sie halt keine Angriffsfläche haben,
der äh also ich sage mal, die die nukleare Option zu sagen, okay, wir schmeißen halt äh,
sage ich mal, bestimmte Keywords aus dem Index, die nicht News sind, sondern die Namen der Zeitung,
und trinken die halt runter auf Seite zwei,
die haben sie natürlich immer noch, aber denen ist natürlich schon klar, dass sie halt einfach dann Kriterienprobleme kriegen könnten, sicherlich nicht in Deutschland, aber auf EU-Ebene, also weil die EU ist natürlich auch irgendwie durchaus bestrebt, gerade da ähm zu regulieren, zum Teil zurecht, zum Teil zu Unrecht.
Also Fazit, wir haben das Gesetz jetzt da, was wie wie übel das am Ende doch noch wird oder nicht. Ähm wird sich erst zeigen, wenn wir die Gerichtsverhandlungen haben. Ja. Und jetzt wird's mal bin ich mal gespannt, wer als erstes zieht.
Ja, genau. Genau, ist das so.
Ja genau, darum geht's eigentlich jetzt, ne? Wer zieht zuerst?
Oder auf das so der kalte Informationskrieg.
Alle in Lauerstellung. So, nicht in Lauerstellung war äh der Bundestag, sondern hat dann auch mutig ein neues Gesetz äh beschlossen, das wir ja auch schon besprochen hatten.
Ja und da kann man sich nämlich eigentlich mal wirklich drüber aufregen. Im Gegensatz zum Leistungsschutzrecht ist das nämlich eins, was uns durchaus betrifft und was, denke ich, auf jeden Fall, dass sehr, sehr viel relevantere Gesetz ist.
Und auch die größere Niederlage närzpolitisch. Ähm das das es einfach durchgegangen ist. Ähm also nämlich die Bestandsdatenauskunft und,
worum's da geht ist, dass die Strafverfolgungsbehörden und auch die Dienste einfachen Zugriff haben sollen auf die,
Daten sind Bestandsdaten insbesondere vom Bildtelefon, Internetanbietern und äh auch der Zugriff zum Beispiel auf die Zuordnung von dynamischer IP-Adresse zu äh den äh,
ja, Bestandsdaten, also wem gehört diese IP-Adresse schon bei quasi geringsten äh Vergehen möglich ist, also auch Ordnungswidrigkeiten, ne?
Muss ich kurz einen Einwand bringen. Die dynamische IP-Adresse ist seit zweitausendachtzehn per Definition Bestandsdatin und nicht mehr Verkehrsdatum.
nämlich also man man grenzt die Bestandsdaten, die so Name, Anschrift, Konto äh äh und so sind von den Verkehrsdaten ab und die IP-Adresse gehört mit einem Urteil seit zweitausendacht irgendwie dann zu den Bestandsdaten.
Weswegen sie halt auch die einfach an die Abmahne weitergeben können.
Na ja, also der, der war interessante Punkt dabei ist halt, dass auch dieses Gesetz hat halt so ein paar Unschärfen, also eines der ähm
Interessanteren ist, dass die Anbieter dazu verpflichtet werden sollen, auch eventuelle äh Zugangskontrolldaten, also sprich zum Beispiel Pins für SIM-Karten oder Pux für SIM-Karten
herauszugeben und das von dem Gesetz ist so schwammig,
dass man daraus durchaus auch ableiten kann, dass äh die Stoffverfolgungsbehörden hingehen könnten und bei Internetserviceprover dann sagen könnten
wir hätten übrigens gerne auch nochmal die Daten, also die die Passworte äh von dem Internet-Account, an dem dann häufiger gerne mal die Mail und was sonst noch so dazu gehört, dranhängt.
Das Wedding ist hier Daten mittels derer der Zugriff auf Endgeräte oder auf Speichereinrichtungen, die in diesen Endgeräten oder hiervon räumlich getrennt eingesetzt werden.
Genau, hiervon räumlich getrennt ist quasi die Cloud.
Das ist dann Dropbox, ja.
Bezieht sich natürlich erstmal nur auf Internetserviceanbieter, beziehungsweise auf Telekommunikationsdienste Anbieter, das heißt also momentan noch nicht auf
Mediendiensteanbieter, diese Trennung in Deutschland gibt's ja immer noch, das heißt also die Leute, die halt Bits schieben, sind die Kommunikationsanbieter, die die Leute, die halt mit den Bits irgendwas machen, sind die Mediendienstanbieter,
die interessante Frage ist halt wann diese Ausdehnung passiert also wann sie dann sagen so was wie Facebook zum Beispiel bietet halt auch Chat an, deswegen sind die halt jetzt mal Kommunikationsdienste Anbieter und deswegen können sie auch an diese Passworte ran. Dann wird's halt interessant. Also klar ist halt diese Bestandsdatenauskunft,
ist halt auf jeden Fall die größere Niederlage im Vergleich zur äh zum Leistungsschutzrecht, hat aber sehr viel weniger Aufmerksamkeit erfahren, also genauer gesagt,
ist das halt völlig an uns vorbei gegangen. Also wir haben das heute also quasi zwei Wochen vorher oder sowas kam enthält dann mal hoch,
Der einzige, der es halt schon ein bisschen länger hat, kommen sie nur Patrick Breier. Ähm und dementsprechend war halt, gab's halt auch keine Mobilisierung. Es gab halt keine, ja, äh,
kein Aufschrei in in die Netzpolitikgremien, ähm die einzigen, die da halt irgendwie ein bisschen was von wussten, waren halt die Netzpolitiker in den Parteien, aber auch die waren, wie ich gehört habe, relativ überrascht, wie schnell es dann ging,
Das ist halt irgendwann doch so rollt da die Polter durch den Innenausschuss ging und dann halt eben durch den Bundestag.
Und das denke ich mal auch so ein Ding, was äh so die zweite Lehre aus dieser Woche,
uns in den letzten zwei Wochen ist eben auch die die lernen halt auch ne? Also ist halt so der je schneller die solche Gesetze durchbringen und die weniger Geräusch desto geringer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es halt irgendwie 'ne.
Aber das Ding muss doch auch im Innenausschuss besprochen worden sein.
Ja, aber die machen's ganz schnell. Also diese, diese Innenausschusssitzung, die also Innenausschuss zu verabschieden im Bundestag war weniger als zwei Wochen.
Das war so, dass die im Innenausschuss äh gab's halt auch Widerspruch natürlich wie immer, also die Experten der anderen Parteien fanden's halt auch nicht so besonders super. Ähm,
Auf der anderen Seite waren aber die, ich sage mal die Opposition der Opposition bis auf die Linken war noch eher so ein bisschen schwammig, also die war eher so na ja, hm, eigentlich im Prinzip ja ganz okay, aber müsste man hier und da noch mal dran tunen. So, also jetzt nicht halt irgendwie so ein irgendwie äh irgendwie.
Fundamental Opposition.
Das geht ja mal gar nicht und ähm daraus resultiert er dann eben auch diese ähm ja, sage mal, dieses dieses etwas ja.
Was jetzt äh ein Politiker, der ähm Koalition jetzt eigentlich auf die Frage sagen würde, was wie sich denn dieses Gesetz bitte verträgt mit dem Grundrecht auf die Integrität unserer äh,
Und Daten, das wir ja vor ein paar Jahren eingeräumt bekommen haben. Ich meine, es ist wieder,
nach Strich und Faden genau diesem Grundrecht.
Na ja, was du dir sagen würdest, dass äh die Weitergabe dessen, wer du bist, also was es ja de facto ist, ähm,
Sind ja zwei Gesetze. Zum einen ist es ein Gesetz zur praktisch Aufhebung von Anonymität im Internet,
Also weil halt irgendwie für geringste Vergehen halt irgendwie äh deine Papierdresse mit irgendwie dann Bestandsdaten gelinkt werden kann. Und zum anderen, zum zweiten eben einen Zugriff auf,
Inhalte,
und die Frage, ob's jetzt irgendwie ein Problem wird, weil zum Beispiel halt irgendwie Landeskriminalämter mit einem einfachen Fax und einer größeren Richterbeschluss halt irgendwie auf Facebook-Passworte zugreifen können. Da werden die sagen, ja, na ja, nee, so haben wir das ja nicht gemeint und das werden die Gerichte ja dann schon verhindern.
Zitat übrigens. So, das ist halt so der das heißt also, was wir da halt auch haben, ist halt ein durchaus,
ja äh schleichendes, heimliches Verhalten auch der Strafverfolgung und der Innenpolitiker da, die halt dann einfach solche Formulierungen da reindrücken,
zu Recht darauf hoffen, dass die halt nicht auffallen oder beziehungsweise nicht halt irgendwie in ihrer vollen Tragweite, also insbesondere dieses mit den Daten, die örtlich davon getrennt gespeichert sind,
ist halt eben diese diese Cloud-Extension und wenn die dann einmal drin ist, dann wird die halt im Zweifel auch benutzt werden und dann ist es halt zu spät. Meine klar ist halt, dieses Gesetz wird nach Karlsruhe gehen,
Also insbesondere diese dieser Zugriff auf die ähm gespeicherten Daten, also Mobiltelefon ist mittlerweile fast noch sensibler als.
Ja, auch Pins, also ich meine, das ist ja schon richtig hardcore.
Ist ja gar nicht so interessant, weil die meisten Leute, die lösch äh ändern oder entfernen, interessant ist die Puck, die Puck ist.
Also ob die meisten Leute ihre PIN ändern, das äh wage ich mal auch schwer zu bezweifeln.
Die meisten Leute schalten sie einfach.
Ändern. Sie könnten sie ändern, ja? Oder also schalten sie ab oder also sie könnten sie zumindest ändern, aber sie kriegen ja auch noch die Puck dazu. Das ist der.
Personal Unlocky.
Ja, das ist also die,
Das ist die Frage, die sie haben ihr ihre PIN vergessen, Frage, die das Telefon.
Na und ähm die also die die interessante Formulierung ist eben dieses Zugriff auf Speichervorrichtung
die von den Endgeräten räumlich getrennt eingesetzt werden. Und die Begründung war halt, dass sie sagten, okay, ähm wenn wir halt in Fotospeicherdienste haben
die vom, also ins Telefon integriert sind und wo du halt auf den Knopf drückst und dann wird halt dann dein Foto haltest dann halt nicht mehr auf dem Telefon, sondern in der Cloud, dann wollen sie halt auch daran.
So, aber diese diese Bezug zum Telefon, also zum Mobilgerät äh ist halt jetzt schon in dieser Formulierung extrem schwammig. Also was das ist, ist es halt quasi ein Ermächtigungsgesetz ein Zugriff,
Liebe geklaut Dienste, wenn sie's so auslegen und anwenden. Und das wird halt garantiert nach Karlsruhe gehen.
Da gibt's natürlich nur das Problem, dass unter normalen Umständen, also wenn man das jetzt mal die technische Realität dahinter ist ja ähm,
dass sie schon immerhin sagen, sie wollen die Zugangsdaten haben in der wenn jetzt aber,
Wirklich zu jemandem, also zu einem vernünftigen Cloud oder sonstwas Anbieter gehst und sagst
Ich möchte gerne das Passwort von der Person haben. Wird er dir das nicht sagen können, weil wenn er sich häufigst an einen vernünftigen Standard äh hält, hat er das Passwort gesortet und gehasht eben wieder liegen und weiß es selber nicht,
Ja, aber das sollte man jetzt schon, also es ist Datenschutz und also auch aus, wie heißt, sie werden halt.
-Sicherheitsgrund.
Gründen der Haftbarkeit. Wenn ich irgendwie äh da bei denen die Büchs aufmache und hundert äh achtzigtausend Passwörter ins Internet äh
die die Leute dann alle noch woanders verwenden, dann haben sie natürlich auch ein Problem mit der Haftbarkeit dafür, dass sie sich eben nicht, dass sie die nicht vernünftig vorgehalten haben. Insofern das Passwort werden die,
eher nicht bekommen können,
Ähm interessant wird's dann, dass natürlich jeder dieser Anbieter sowieso nochmal die Schnittstelle hat, dann eben den Zugriff auf die Daten zu erlangen.
was weiß ich, die äh selbstverständlich liegen meine E-Mails auf dem E-Mail-Server meines Anbieters so vor, dass er sie selber auch.
Um's vielleicht mal ein bisschen konkreter zu machen. Also angenommen dieses Bestandsdatengesetz ist jetzt irgendwie umgesetzt und gültig. Weiß gar nicht, wann soll das in Kraft treten?
Das muss noch durch den Bundesrat. Da es aber kein Widerstand zu erwarten.
Das BK ist SPD geführt, also was erwartet man für einen Widerstand?
Ja, so und dann heißt das, das ist noch dieses Jahr in Kraft tritt.
Das kann tatsächlich noch vor den Wahlen in Kraft treten, ja.
Okay, so und jetzt nehmen wir mal an, das ist jetzt in Kraft,
Was heißt das konkret? Also was in welchem Fall kann welche äh welcher Teil des Staates kann jetzt worauf,
unter welchen Umständen zugreifen, was er vorher nicht konnte. Das ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar.
Na die, also es gibt da zwei Dinge. Zum einen, das sind die äh die Hürde,
für welche Vergehen oder Straftaten es halt eingesetzt werden kann, die ist halt quasi null, das heißt also auch sowas wie irgendwie falsch parken im Internet, also.
In der Einbahnstraße.
Genau, beliebige,
beliebig niedrige äh Vergehen ähm sind halt irgendwie dann auskunftsfähig. So und dazu gehört halt eben auch sowas wie irgendwie Beleidigung,
so oder äh Dinge, die die halt sonst bisher im Internet unter Kinkellecin gefallen sind. Ähm,
Sind dann halt auskunftsfähig. So und das heißt halt, dass also auch äh jeder, der sich im Internet aufs auf den Schlips getreten fühlt, wird dieses äh wird halt irgendwie hingehen und äh,
dann halt einen äh ja eine Auskunft verlangen.
Ja und dann? Also das ist eine Auskunft für Dritte oder nur eine Auskunft für die äh Ermittlungsbehörden?
Na erstmal für die Ermittlungsbehörden, aber die kann natürlich für Dritte verwendet werden, wenn Haltung geht, keine Ahnung, zum Beispiel es halt um Beleidigungen oder ähnliche Dinge geht. Wenn du halt hingehst, Beleidigungsanzeige stellst, können die halt diese Daten rausrücken. Und die ähm äh die.
Welche Daten ausrücken.
Die Bestandsdaten. Also die die na die Zuordnung äh der IP-Adresse zum Beispiel zum äh ja äh zum zur Person.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja doch heute schon genauso möglich.
Ja, aber nicht ohne richterlichen Beschluss.
Das ist dann ohne richterlichen Beschluss. Super.
Tatsächlich der einfach.
Na gut, nicht, dass der richterliche Beschluss jetzt eine große Hürde dargestellt hatte, ne.
Na der ist halt insofern schon eine Hürde, weil er halt einen gewissen Aufwand erzeugt und die Strafenfondsbehörden müssen dit da halt hingehen und sich den Beschluss holen und der Richter macht.
Man kann das nicht ganz so industriell äh.
Also man kann gut also der dieser Richter die Beschluss ist halt eine Durchstempelangelegenheit, aber er hat zumindest gewisse Hürden. So, das machen die halt nicht wegen jeder Ordnungswidrigkeit,
Deshalb muss halt zumindest schon mal irgendwie so ein bisschen Straftat muss da halt schon passiert sein, damit halt irgendwie sowas passiert. Und da ist es dann halt nicht mehr so. Und was halt auch heißt, dass die Polizei halt zum Beispiel, wenn sie ein Telefon bei jemand beschlagnahmt, den sie halt irgendwo wegfahren
dass sie nicht mal irgendeine Art von großartiger Eingriffstiefe braucht um zu kommen von dem Telefon.
Weil sie einfach die Pucke hinterfragen können und zack.
Genau. Und halt eben doch auf die die Daten, die halt auf entsprechende äh entsprechenden Diensten, die halt zum Beispiel zu einem Mobiltelefonanbieter gehören,
gespeichert sind,
und ähm und das ist halt eben doch das Problem an diesem Gesetzes, dass es halt in seiner Unschärfe und in seinem seiner weitreichen, weitreichung äh garantiert kreativ genutzt wird.
Aber ich meine, was was können sie denn mit der PIN äh mit dem Mobiltelefon schon groß machen? Ich meine, sie können dann irgendwie auf seine Kosten.
Naja, der die interessante Frage ist, ob's halt eben nur die PIN ist, ne? Also, ob's halt, also war eben dieses äh Datenmittel, derer Zugriff auf Endgeräte, heißt halt im Zweifel auch Anlock Codes, heißt halt im Beispiel Passworte, heißt Passwort Reset Mechanismen.
Und da wird's dann halt schon interessant. Und Mobilgeräte sind halt eben nicht nur dein Telefon, da sind halt auch deine iPads.
Meine gefährlichste Einfallstür ist ja eigentlich Mehl.
Klar, weil du damit halt alles risetten kannst, ja. Mhm.
Weil du damit heutzutage eigentlich alles resenden kannst so, ne? Aber Domains sind jetzt hier sozusagen Kontrolle über die Domains äh übernehmen.
Also nehmen wir mal an, du bist halt irgendwie so ein typischer Kunde und hast halt deine E-Mail bei Timo bei,
oder T-Online. So, dann bist du halt wenn wenn sie diese Daten wollen, dann rücken die halt raus,
zu großes Endgerät, weil darüber kannst du halt dann den für irgendwie den Anlockcode durchführen und drauf,
wie sagt man, was halt die konkreten Auswirkungen sein werden, hängt halt davon ab, wie kreativ die die Strafverfolgungsbehörden und die Dienste total interpretieren und äh,
anfangen. So und das werden wir halt noch sehen und ist halt eben genau auch diese, das ist halt wie so ein typisches Beispiel von so einem so einem Gesetz, wo halt,
sie die Kontroverse, die halt,
Details entstehen könnte. Also man halt sich auseinandersetzen müsste, will man diesen diese Eingriffsbefugnisse oder will man die nicht? Und wenn ja, warum will man sie vielleicht nicht oder warum will man sie?
halt wieder an die Gerichte delegiert haben und gesagt haben, so ja, wir formulieren's halt mal so ein bisschen vager.
Was tun.
Wir mussten was tun, ne? Die Strafverfolger haben da halt wieder mal ihre Akten ausgepackt irgendwie mit den Millionen Vergewaltigten der Kinder. Und dann äh,
Irgendwie an die äh ja, wir brauchen halt, wir brauchen halt,
Das ist halt so dieser dieses typische Vorgehen dann. Die interessante Frage ist, ob da jetzt noch mehr kommt. Also ob dies dann noch im Koalitionsvertrag wieder Sachen finden, die sie dann noch lieber mal schnell umsetzen.
Linus, so machen wir was beizutragen zu dem Thema.
Was wir ein bisschen außen vorgelassen haben ist natürlich, dass das vor allem für die freudigen Fallsharer jetzt auch nochmal Konsequenzen haben wird, weil es noch sehr, sehr viel schneller gehen wird. Und da jetzt auch einfach,
der Zugriff einfacher wird, das heißt, die Abmahner freuen sich da jetzt durch.
Abmahnindustrieförderungsgesetz.
Ja, die brauchen die brauchen keinen richterlichen Beschluss mehr. Ähm so übrigens auch in einem Argument, was halt am Rande eine Diskussion kam, dass es halt eben doch durchaus um eine Entlastung der Justiz ginge.
Das ist super so. Ja, das die Gerichte werden schon entscheiden, aber die haben mir zu viel zu tun, also nehmen wir sie am besten noch mal raus. Genau. Mhm.
Super.
Ja, toller Rechtsstaat, ne.
Ganz toll. Na ja mal gucken, also da sehe ich ja auch so ein bisschen noch Karlsruhe mäßig äh.
Also denke ich mal, das wird nach Karlsruhe gehen, also wird wieder zwei Jahre dauern, ist halt das Problem. Und in der Zeit wird halt viel Schaden passieren.
Linus, weiter.
Ja, hier kommt das nächste, was ich vorhergesagt habe. Ähm.
Kristallkugel.
Das ist alles in meinem Kopf. Die Kristallkugel ist in meinem Kopf.
So ein bisschen.
Ähm.
Das BKA berichtet einerseits, also wir kennen ja glaube ich alle
zwei Monate darauf hinweist, dass das BKA immer noch Staatstrojaner-Entwickler sucht. Das liegt aber daran, dass sie äh hundertfünfzig an der Zahl, glaube ich, suchen, also irgendwie völlig utopische Zahl. Und sagen, sie haben aber zahlreiche Bewerbungen
Ja, läuft alles super hier, läuft das Projekt. Aber äh vermutlich um eine Schutzlücke äh zu schließen, wollen sie bis.
Eine temporäre Schutzlücke.
Wollen sie natürlich verhindern? Äh wollen sie, wollen sie quasi bis sie dann selber einen Staatstrojaner entwickelt haben? Wollen.
Das ist also Gefahrenverzug, ja.
Zunächst bei äh doch dann das Produkt von Gamma International, der Firma, über die wir ja schon häufig berichtet haben.
Und wo du schon vor einem Jahr, glaube ich, äh prophezeit hast, dass äh die da demnächst mal. Mhm.
Ja? Und genau das ist jetzt der Fall,
ähm das Produkt, also der Gamma äh Finn Fischer, die Suite ist also äh sehr, sehr offensichtlich mit dem deutschen äh ähm
mit den deutschen legalen Voraussetzungen nicht vereinbar, genauso wenig wie es das äh Produkt von Digital Square
Gamma in seinem Funktionsumfang und auch in seiner äh Raffinesse bei weitem übertrifft.
Ähm und jetzt ist also ganz klar, dass BKA wird relativ bald dann bei Gamma diese,
Dieses diese Deutschland Edition des Ägypten Trojaners kaufen. Und hat sich dafür eine Anzeige der Piratenpartei am Bundesrechnungshof,
eingefangen wegen misswirtschaft. Ähm die Piratenpartei merkt an, dass es relativ äh offensichtlich ist, dass dieses Produkt nicht verwende.
Es kann sich nicht um eine Anzeige handeln, weil man kann beim Bundesrechnungshof niemand anzeigen im Sinne von zur Polizei gehen und anzeigen. Man kann vielleicht drauf hinweisen.
Ich.
Anzeigen kann man dann nicht.
Ich ich war auch etwas überrascht, aber sie haben.
Die Piraten haben das so formuliert, glaube ich.
Genau, ja, das haben sie also wir haben eine Beschwerde geschrieben oder so, ne? Also weißt du,
Sie sagen dem der Rechnungshof soll auf jeden Fall prüfen, ob das PKA da im Prinzip ähm gegen das Gebot der wirtschaftlichen und sparsamen Mittelverwendung verstößt.
ähm ich weiß nicht, wenn man, wenn man schon über die Schiene kommen muss, dann sieht man, wie wie machtlos man ist im Rahmen dieses Bereichs. Ähm.
Der Bundesrechnungshof hat ja sozusagen überhaupt gar keine.
Kann ja nur du du sagen, ja.
Ja, der kann nur du du sagen, der der veröffentlicht hast und sagst so, na das war aber jetzt mal nicht so schön,
Hättet ihr ja mal vorher darüber nach äh denken können, so das war's, so also sozusagen die maximale äh Bestrafung. Ich meine, man man könnte jetzt sagen, okay, sie haben da zumindest so einen Öffentlichkeits äh Aufmerksamkeitsloch.
Es gibt da eine, es gibt da eine Zahl, die kolportiert wird, bei der ich nicht genau weiß, wie realistisch sie ist und dass diese Zahl ist einhundertfünfzigtausend Euro und das sind die äh bezifferten Kosten für einen Einsatz.
Für einen Einsatz.
Das ist die Zahl, die ich da lese. Und ähm.
Also laut Merz und Bahrenhof der Piraten.
Jede, dass jeder für einen Fischereinsatz mit einem Betrag zwischen einhundertfünfzigtausend Euro und einer nicht genannten siebenstelligen Summe zu Buche schlage. Ähm.
Und einer nicht genannten siebenstelligen.
Zwischen hundertfünfzigtausend und einer nicht es geht ab hundertfünfzigtausend geht's los.
Einnimmt, sagen. Okay.
Ähm,
Das halte ich jetzt, also ich weiß nicht, wie realistisch diese Zahl ist. Wenn, man sagt, der Einsatz geht ab hundertfünfzigtausend Euro los, dann finde ich das ganz gut, weil dann weiß ich, dass ich das wahrscheinlich nicht wert bin für die.
Glauben sie alle.
Das glaubt ihr. Ja. Ja ich ich äh.
Schätze mal deinen Wert jetzt nicht zu gering ein, Linus.
Auf jeden Fall ist kann es nicht sehr viel billiger sein,
Oder es kann billiger sein, aber auf jeden Fall nicht sportbillig sein, weil Gammer natürlich enorme Kosten auch hat, dieses Produkt äh,
herzustellen. Ja, die, ich hatte das ja schon mal hier in der Folge ausgeführt. Die müssen konstant weiterentwickeln und müssen auch vor allem in in Schienen weiterentwickeln. Ähm müssen also ihre Backups, Backup-Möglichkeiten haben, also Backup in dem
also eine Version entdeckt wird, wie das.
Kaufen.
Schön einkaufen, äh Leute kaufen und die entwickeln das Ding sicherlich nicht vollständig selber, sondern kaufen eher ein. Ähm.
Werdet ihr jetzt hier bitte das Target ist.
Na ja, der Punkt ist halt, machen sie also geht's dabei darum, ob sie äh quenti KÖ machen oder ob sie tatsächlich äh einen Trojaner einsetzen.
Also weil der Punkt ist halt, dass die,
ähm die Quellen TKÜ Nummer ähm wollen sie eigentlich gerne haben, aber ihnen ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch klar.
Quellenticker üben im Sinne von Abschnorcheln auf meinem eigenen Rechner, wenn ich da skype, et cetera.
Quellenticket ist der Versuch zu sagen, ähm,
Wir machen ein Limited Trojaner, der halt nur Telekommunikation abschnorchen kann. Ist halt Bullshit, weil ein Trojaner infiltrierten rechnen und kannst alles damit machen. Ähm,
Und dafür gibt's ja dieses, dieses Loch in dem Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil, wo sie gesagt haben, wenn's halt nur um Telekommunikation geht, dann,
sind halt niedrigere Voraussetzungen anzulegen. Also das heißt, dann kann man mit einem richterlichen Beschluss und oder vielleicht ein bisschen mehr arbeiten,
hingegen, wenn's halt um den vollständigen Turaner geht, also die komplette Infiltration des Computers, dann muss man halt irgendwie Kernbereichsschutz und äh diese ganzen Dinge in in Betracht ziehen. Also,
den den die ganze Zeit da. Ähm und die interessante Frage ist jetzt halt, worum geht's denn da eigentlich konkret? Ne, also ist halt also der,
Wollen Sie dabei Gamma halt den, sage mal, den den vollständigen Bundestreuer, der sich halt eben nach den Maßgaben des Verfassungsgerichtsurteils also halt irgendwie komplette Kernbereichsschutz irgendwie drei Richter und so weiter und so fort. Ähm,
Oder wollen sie halt sich dann einen Quellen Telekommunikationstrojaner Schusterzusammenschuß verlassen. Das ist halt noch so ein bisschen unklar, was worum's da eigentlich geht. Bei hundertfünfzigtausend Euro für einen Abhöreinsatz machen die nicht,
hundertfünfzigtausend Euro für die irgendwie Handvoll Einsätze, die sie de facto nach dem, dem Verfassungsgerichtsurteil irgendwie hinkriegen können, äh ist realistisch, dass halt so die Größenordnung, die sie halt irgendwie machen für äh zum Beispiel auch für Wanzeneinbau.
Also das ist halt so ein, ne, am am Ende ist das halt eben die Frage dann halt, was was tun sie, wenn sie merken, dass es halt irgendwie teuer und lästig ist?
einzusetzen.
Selber einen entwickeln.
Nein, nein, auch dann wird's teuer und lustig sein.
Selbstverständlich.
Trojaner Trojaner-Einsatz ist halt irgendwie mal teuer und lästig und da wird auch kein Weg dran vorbeiführen. Und ich habe eher so ein bisschen Sorge vor dem Tag, wo sie irgendwie das feststellen. Also wo sie merken, dass es halt irgendwie äh.
Ja aber was können was könnte denn jetzt hier ein realistisches Target sein, dass es ähm BKA tatsächlich äh so einen finanziellen Aufwand auch leisten möchte? Ich meine, das ist doch jetzt wirklich so top Terror.
Ja, es sind halt die, es sind halt, man ist halt quasi dieselben Leute, die sie halt heute mit einem großen Laufsteingriff äh verfolgen, so sind halt irgendwie so aus zwanzig Einsätze im Jahr, das heißt also heute, wie tatsächlich ihre Handvoll, linke Hand von Beladen, Terroristen
irgendwie zwei, drei Großdrogenhändler und zwei, drei Menschenschmuggler so, also das hat so, also ich denke mal, das ist halt so ein
eben auch wirklich so eine, also das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil, wenn es denn tatsächlich so angewendet wird, wie es da steht, was noch die große Frage ist
ist zumindest, wenn's um den vollen Zugriff den Computer geht, also halt eben das komplette Exultieren äh ist dann halt
eben nicht was, was sie heute mal jeden Tag machen können, weswegen sie unbedingt ja diese Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung haben wollen, weil sie da ja quasi mit na irgendwie einfachen Stempelvoraussetzungen zumindest nach jetzigen Stand der der Interpretation rangehen können und
deswegen ist ja unter anderem auch eine Forderung halt irgendwie für zum Beispiel die Landesgesetze, wo es jetzt in Berlin zum Beispiel darum ging, bauen die sich jetzt ein Quellentelekommunikationstrojaner
ähm wo dann halt einfach auch die Experten gesagt haben, so, na ja, dann äh regelt doch lieber erst mal irgendwie den normalen Trojanereinsatz ordentlich. Ähm,
Weil dann habt ihr den Quellentelekommunikationstrojaner auch mit abgedeckt, weil der ist genauso lästig schwierig und äh äh rechtlich problematisch.
Na ja, also die diese Posse da äh mit dem mit dem BKA hat ja noch diesen äh äh,
dieses Pflichtenheft, das spielt ja auch noch da mit rein. Habt ihr das schon mal betrachtet?
Ich hab's mir, ich hab's mir angeschaut, aber wir haben's in der Sendung nicht behandelt, nee. In dem das irgendwie, es muss ja immer so ein hast du, vielleicht kannst du ein, was du da was daraus zu zitieren ist.
Na dieses Pflichtenheft äh äh ist ja.
Die Anforderung.
Genau. Ist ja der Versuch zu sagen, ähm wir,
alle LKAs tun sich zusammen und sagen, das ist, was wir als Trojaner haben wollen. Also, was es halt können muss und danach muss sich dann der Hersteller richten und auf der Basis dieses Pflichtenheftes evaluieren, weil halt die Software. Das heißt also, der muss dann halt irgendwie ähm,
ich verschlüsselt Kommunikation nach Hause oder äh solche Dinge und ähm,
da stehen dann halt so Kochen drinnen in diesem in diesem Pflichtenheft, wo man sich dann schon fragt, so was für Spezialexperten daran mitgeschrieben haben. Das schreiben sie zum Beispiel so was wie
Ja, also offensichtlich, aber dass sie überhaupt drüber nachgedacht haben, nach heutigem Stand der Technik ist eine automatische Trennung von
Falldaten und Kernbereichsrelevanten Daten nicht möglich. Das heißt, dass die überhaupt darüber nachgedacht haben, sich,
so dachten sie, wenn da irgendwie was wollten die sich da irgendwie eine Stöhnerkennung bauen oder so oder ist ja so völlig unklar, na ja.
Ja, wollen wir weiterschreiten? Was gibt's denn noch Neues?
Ja, wir haben, während wir, wenn wir diesen ganzen Kram machen, gibt's jetzt ein ein schönes Gesetz in der Schublade, dass wir in Deutschland für
Gerichtsfeste Kommunikation für die Kommunikation mit Ämtern ähm,
Da tatsächlich unsere Sicherheitsstandards senken wollen. Und zwar gibt es seit zweitausendelf ja mit D Mail das äh Angebot für den sicheren Geschäftsverkehr für jedermann. Es soll also eine
sichere Alternative zu E-Mail sein, mit der man dann ähm sage ich mal so seinen seinen täglichen Behördengang oder so abhandeln kann,
und ähm.
Wirklich so geil.
Das ist also.
Der geht also wirklich so diese die Traute irgendwie über dich zu haben so mit ja äh E-Mail, so wie es im Internet ist, das das verstehen wir nicht irgendwie und das das kann's ja wohl nicht sein. Wir machen jetzt Deutschland.
Was was verbirgt sich denn hinter dement? Ich meine, der Grundgedanke ist schon mal klar, dass du als dass du jetzt nicht irgendwie, also dass E-Mail nicht das geeignete Kommunikationsmedium ist, um wirklich, sage ich mal, äh.
Staatsverbindliches enorm.
Das heißt, sie sagen, okay, wir machen diesen D-Mail-Standard
Und ähm wenn man den nutzen möchte, dann muss man sich irgendwie mit einem Personalausweis irgendwo registrieren, dann machen wir eine verifizieren wir die Identität dieser Person und
dann, wenn sie sich dazu angemeldet hat, nutzen wir irgendwie so ein bisschen den gleichen E-Mail-Sicherheitskram, den den jetzt heute schon,
Google ungefähr nutzt und äh aber jeder, der das anbieten möchte, muss irgendwie sich vom BSI über, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Seiten auch wieder
durch so ein Pflichtenheft lesen und zertifizieren lassen, kostet alles ein Riesengeld. Und wunderbarerweise können wir dafür sorgen, dass wir unsere deutsche ähm,
deutschen Anbieter da einfach mal auch ein bisschen bisschen Geld reinspielen, weil ist natürlich auch kostenpflichtig, ja? Eine D-Mail zu versenden kostet Geld.
Aber das reduziert auch den Spam, ne?
Das reduziert den Spam, ja, der.
Bringen, das bringen die echt als Argument, ne?
Also ja, ein bei einem Dienst, wo man sich mit Personalausweis anmelden muss, kriegst du nicht so viel Spam, ja, das, das stimmt.
machen wir uns mal nicht über alles lustig. Es ist schon ähm der Gedanke ist ja nicht so blöd, das mal zu machen,
der Gedanke, dass dann aber nicht zu nutzen ist auch nicht blöd, ja? Und der diesen Gedanken hatten bis jetzt alle, also einfach bisher nicht genutzt, das gibt's ja schon seit einiger Zeit und das wurde irgendwie.
Also für so ein paar Pilotversuche, wo es genutzt.
Es wurde schon mal so eil, es hat schon mal eine Test-D-Mail geschickt, ne? Und ähm.
Irgendwie durchgeschnitten und dann.
Was war, was war.
Die rote E-Mail-Schleife,
mit der goldenen Schere.
Gedauert, der Goldene Schere.
Was war schon zweitausendelf
Das Problem, diese D-Mail wird ähm sicher übertragen, also ich ich klicke bei mir auf ich möchte senden und dann wird diese D-Mail äh durch einen
es ist SSL-Verbindung äh geschickt und wird dann bei meinem Provider, in dem Fall, sagen wir mal jetzt T, sonstwas oder was, wird sie dann äh
Wieder entschlüsselt und der schaut sie sich dann an, macht einen Virenscan, ja, irgendwoher irgendwo für muss das Geld ja gut sein, was ich dafür bezahle, fünfundsiebzig Cent oder so.
Frisches Snack-Oi.
Ja, da wird also ein Viren.
Soll das kosten? Fünfundsiebzig Cent.
Ja, wenn ich den, das ist, glaube ich, der Betrag, den ich im Kopf habe. Ja, warte, geht hier noch weiter? Da geht der, weiter, es wird ja alles noch witziger. Da macht er also diesen Viren.
SMS Nachfolger, ja.
Also die Begründung ist auch geil. Die sagen, na ja, ist es halt besser als ein Brief, weil es ja authentifiziert ist. Also es ist ja quasi eigentlich wie ein Einschreiben.
Also muss das auch so viel kosten werden.
Und dann kostet's nur halb so viel wie ein Einschreiben.
Oh, Discount.
So und dann dann wird diese dann verschlüsselt der die wieder und schickt die an den an den Anbieter desjenigen an den ich äh an denen ich meine E-Mail,
an meine D-Mail adressiert habe und dort wird sie wieder unverschlüsselt vorgehalten und dann holt er sie dort irgendwann über eine verschlüsselte Verbindung ab. Das ist aber ungefähr das, was bei einer normalen E-Mail heute auch passiert. So, das Spannende wäre ja jetzt gewesen,
Wenn sie dafür gesorgt hätten, dass die D-Mail vernünftig signiert und vernünftig Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt wird,
Das war jetzt echt mal, da hätten sie was geschaffen, nämlich.
Ach das ist nicht so.
Nein, der DL fehlt, die Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Es ist wirklich nur, es ist von einer E-Mail.
Damit man da Viren scannen kann oder was.
Also, dass die offizielle Begründung.
Das ist die offizielle Begründung. Ja, selbstverständlich, die offizielle Begründung ist, ja, also es gibt zwei offizielle Gründe. Ähm,
Erstens Ende zur Endeverschlüsselung ist kompliziert, weil dafür bräuchte man eine Zusatzsoftware,
Ja, äh wie ich sie auch für D-Mail brauche, also ich werde jetzt schon durch den wenn ich schon durch den Prozess laufe, ähm,
Mir irgendwie da mich zu authentifizieren, um diesen blöden Account zu bekommen, irgendwie einen monatlichen Beitrag dafür zu bezahlen, ja, mir einen eigenen D-Mail-Client äh zu installieren, beziehungsweise momentan nutzen die Leute das übers Webinterface, was ja dann auch nochmal äh ganz andere
anderen Angriffen, Tür und Tor öffnet. Ähm,
Dann haben sie also gesagt, so die zwei Klicks, die jetzt noch notwendig wären, um so eine S-Mim sowas noch da mit reinzuballern, ne. Und zum Beispiel, sie hätten die Gelegenheit gehabt, eine eine Bundes äh äh zertifiziert zu machen.
Ja, das machen wir endlich mal so richtiges S mal im Zertifikat bekommen vom irgendwie Deutschland und kostenlos oder beziehungsweise welchen Kosten auch immer da.
Zertifikat kann man dir ja kostenlos geben, welche Proteinmelder dann fünfundsiebzig Cent.
Ja, das denke ich allerdings auch, ne. Also, ich meine, ich registriere mich auf da mitm Personalausweis hin und mache nicht, was für ein Scheiß irgendwie dann dafür auch noch, weil meistens kostet das Geld und kaum einer benutzt, erstmal genau, weil es irgendwie keine
wirklich gut verbindlichen Zertifikate gibt, außer jetzt innerhalb von Firmen.
Genau. Also sie hätten da, sie hätten da wirklich eine Chance gehabt, um was zu Vernünftiges zu machen. Ob man das jetzt nutzen möchte am Ende, steht dann ja nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. So, jetzt ähm haben sie festgestellt, okay, diesen Demerkram nutzt keiner,
Und nach dem jetzigen Stand darf das auch keiner nutzen, weil es keine Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung hat. Und
unter bestimmten Umständen wäre das also
fahrlässiger Geheimnisverrat etwas über diese unsichere D-Mail zu senden, die ja dokumentiert und wissen
wissentlich von mehreren Stationen auf dem Weg der Übertragung unverschlüsselt betrachtet und sogar behandelt wird mit mit diesen Virenscanner.
Aber wir haben für diese technischen Probleme eine richtige Lösung.
Für die technischen Probleme eine.
Also laut welcher Gesetzeslage ist das denn das und zu.
Kann ich dir, kann ich dir gleich alles sagen? Ich habe da ja eine schöne Stellungnahme für drüber geschrieben für den äh CCC, der so freundlich war, mich da auch als,
Äh Sachverständiger in den Innenausschuss zu entsenden,
indem ich dann in äh in der Woche, in der du im Urlaub warst, habe ich hier äh Stellungnahmen geschrieben und ähm war im Innenausschuss. Das war äh auch nochmal eine ganz spannende ähm ganz spannende Erfahrung. Und zwar findet sich der schöne Satz darin,
da soll also ein Gesetz geändert werden und dieser Satz, den muss man auch durchaus zitieren, ich hatte ihn,
Wo ist er denn? Da wollen Sie also die Abgabenordnung ändern, irgendwie in einen Paragraph ergänzen, dem Absatz eins wird folgender Satz hinzugefügt,
Die kurzzeitige automatisierte Entschlüsselung,
die beim Versenden einer D-Mail-Nachricht durch den akkreditierten Diensteanbieter zum Zweck der Überprüfung auf Schadsoftware und zum Zweck der Weiterleitung an den Adressaten der D-Mail-Nachricht erfolgt, verstößt nicht gegen das Verschlüsselungsgebot des Satzes drei.
Ähm das das mal eine Nachricht zum Zweck der Weiterleitung entschlüsseln muss, ist natürlich.
Es ist eine Änderung innerhalb welches Gesetzes?
Äh das war jetzt also den den Absatz findest du, findest du mehrfach. Den diesen Satz findest du mehrfach.
Also im im Kern geht's halt um die Abgabenordnung, also damit das Finanzamt die halt dann äh irgendwie Dinge über die E-Mail aufdrücken kann.
Gabenordnung des Finanzamtes verstehe, okay.
Äh Gleiches findet sich irgendwie im Sozialgesetzbuch ähm und ja, zwei Artikeln äh zur Abgabenordnung. So, jetzt ähm das heißt, im Klartext.
Was ist das eigentlich auch für ein.
Wir wissen, dass D Mail nicht unserem Verschlüsselungsgebot genügt.
Es genügt nicht dem Verschlüsselungsgebot. Und deswegen schreiben wir hin, wenn's aber eine D-Mail ist, dann muss es nicht weiter verschlüsselt sein.
Weil das ja sicher, weil es steht ja DE drauf.
Also genügt nicht unseren Anforderungen, deswegen machen wir einen Absatz hinzu und sagen, wenn's D-MEL ist, äh ist es verstößt es nicht gegen unsere Anforderungen.
Ist super.
Ja
Ab.
Das kannst du dir nicht ausdenken so.
Deswegen also wie gesagt, also der Punkt ist halt noch mal, es geht halt dann nicht darum, dass sie's nicht wissen, sondern sie wollen nicht.
Das ist genau der Fakt. Ich habe denen das ja dann also es war war ganz interessant. Ich habe eigentlich bin ich in dieser in dieser Anhörung gegangen und habe gedacht, die werden mich gar nicht fragen, weil,
Äh ja, Bosbach und Uhl im Innenausschuss sitzen und unter meinem Namen Chaos Computerclub stand,
insofern, ne, der Chaot aus dem Computerclub, den will man ja im Innenausschuss vielleicht gar nicht haben. Das Gegenteil war dann der Fall. Und zwar haben mich alle Fraktionen die ganze Zeit gefragt,
und ähm ich war derjenige, der da am meisten gesprochen hat.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich auch sehr, sehr wenigen die Ahnung gehabt haben.
Ja, also da ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht. Also ich ich habe mich natürlich gefreut, äh da äh
Als CCC sprechen zu können, ähm allerdings sage ich mal trugen jetzt die anderen Sachverständigen nicht zu meiner Ehre bei. Es waren irgendwie dann noch der Herr Doktor Roleder, dass so der,
Lobbyist von Bitcoin, vom Bitco.
Bestimmt ganz toll fand.
Ja selbstverständlich, weil jeder DML-Anbieter Mitglied des Bitcom ist, ja, das ist ja äh staatliche äh Förderung seines Bereichs, der muss das ja toll finden,
Interessant war dann und da muss ich dann jetzt mal den, wie heißt er denn? Höferling. Höferling zitieren, der äh.
Verliehen, ne? Hier, genau, ja.
Von der FDP, der dann sagte, ja.
Geordneter oder was.
Abgeordneter im Bund im Innenausschuss, der dann sagte, ja ähm,
Ich sollte ihm das jetzt nochmal genau erklären mit der mit der Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung, wie denn die Sachen auf das äh auf die Geräte kommen.
Und dann habe ich ihm das erklärt, wie das so bei meinem bei meinem iPhone oder meinem Blackberry funktioniert und dass ich dadurch äh Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte E-Mails senden kann und dass das alles äh sich im Rahmen hält und dann sagte er, ja ähm,
Aber wie ist das denn, wenn ich wenn man im Urlaub ist, in der Türkei und dort in ein Internetcafé geht,
wie ich denn da meine Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt E-Mails abhole?
Dann habe ich ihm gesagt, dass ich das äh einem Internetcafe nicht mache, weil ich da dem Gerät nicht trauen kann, ja, dass ich da weder Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte, noch nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Nachrichten abholen kann und dass sich das System ähm.
Er möchte also gerne seinen Finanzamt Jahreseinkommensteuererklärung irgendwie net.
Im Internetcafe in der Türkei schicken.
Scheiße.
Ich meine, da sieht man mal wieder, was für interessante Gewohnheiten unsere Politiker so haben, ne?
Aber das ist natürlich, also da muss man, okay, da können wir jetzt drüber lachen. Da muss man natürlich.
Immer hinter immerhin hat er nicht Thailand gesagt.
Egal wie sicher das,
Egal, wie sicher das Verfahren ist, was ich dann nutze, gegen ein Gerät, dem ich nicht trauen kann, äh kann ich mich da nicht schützen? Ähm,
Insofern ähm ja, da habe ich dann den den Endgegner argumentativ, denke ich dann durchaus besiegt. Ähm,
Trotzdem interessiert sich natürlich keiner für das, was ich gesagt habe, ne. Es war dann irgendwie so ähm.
Ähm was den Drachen besiegt, aber es gab keine Prinzessin.
Es gab keine Prinzessin,
Ähm ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich ich nenne jetzt mal die Person, die dann nachher am Fahrstuhl zu mir kam und sagte ich weiß ja, dass sie Recht haben,
Ähm nenne ich jetzt nicht namentlich, aber der habe ich natürlich auch gesagt, ja gut, dann hätten sie da drin sagen müssen, ne. Es hilft mir ja nicht, wenn ich, wenn mir am Ende äh gesteckt wird, ja, wir wissen, du hattest Recht, aber äh verstehst ja, ähm,
ist ja Innenausschuss, ne? Kann. So, kurz noch dazu meine Hauptargumentation.
Innenausschuss hat nichts mit Logik zu tun.
So, es gibt also zwei Probleme ähm oder das das Problem, was ich sehe, ist ähm dadurch, dass das so wenige Anbieter sind,
machst du natürlich diese Server und wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, gesetzlich dürfen da wirklich relevante Daten drüber gesendet werden. Und zwar so relevante Daten, dass es den Personen fünfundsiebzig Cent wert ist, die darüber zu schicken
Das macht den Server, auf dem dieser ganze Kram liegt, natürlich zum relativ attraktiven Angriffsziel. Das war die Argumentation, mit der ich versucht habe, dem Innenausschuss das näher zu bringen und das hat sie auch
durchaus interessiert. Ähm was sie anscheinend aber noch mehr interessiert, ist,
Und da kann ich sie zumindest nachvollziehen, wenn ich als,
Bundesregierung jetzt wirklich so ein Ende zu Ende verschlüsseltes sicheres Kommunikationssystem meinen Bürgern aufstelle,
Dann äh tue ich mir da eventuell keinen großen Gefallen mit. Vor allem wenn ein Trojanereinsatz hundertfünfzigtausend Euro kostet,
Also ähm das ist.
Das ist.
Ja, also das das scheint dann natürlich die rationalste sein. Da da ging einfach das Memo mal rum, ja klar.
Meinst du, da war ich meine bei na gut, aber ich meine, wenn sie dann eh quälen TKÜ auf meinem Rechner an.
Ja, ja, aber sie bei D-Mail haben sie natürlich.
Aber das müssen sie ja sozusagen auch erst tun und so können sie ja dann bei ihren Freunden bei der Bitcom äh sozusagen die TKÜ dann sozusagen machen, so wie sie es bisher auch gewohnt sind mit den Telekommunikationsunternehmen.
Die muss ja auch die muss er ja sogar per Gesetz dann sein. Also das ist das ist ganz klar, dass die opfern da äh einen großen Aspekt der Sicherheit dieses Verfahrens, für die Möglichkeit, das alles schön überwachen zu können. Ist in dem Moment scheißegal, weil es wird also
Wenn's überhaupt jemand nutzt, dann eben für die Steuererklärung, die kriegen sie ja ohnehin. Insofern ähm also ich sehe da drei Möglichkeiten. Die erste.
Dann kommt ein PDF vom Finanzamt dann gleich noch der Trojaner zurück.
Das war.
Der Interessante, der Hammer ist ja, das haben wir ja vorhergesagt, ne?
Also wir haben ja einen Aprilscherz gemacht, wo wir gesagt haben, äh wie Elster, also diese elektronische Steuerabgabe äh Geschichte. Ich glaube, zweitausendsieben haben wir den gemacht oder so zweitausendsechs. Äh
Bundestrojaner und,
Der Hammer ist, diesen Aprilscherz sind wir nie wieder losgeworden, ne? Wir kriegen immer noch Anfragen dazu
ob das denn wahr sei, ob wir denn da irgendwie mal einen Beweis für gehabt hätten, Entschuldigung, könnte aufs Datum gucken, so. Und jetzt holt uns sozusagen die die Wahrheit unseren Aprilscherz ein, ne?
Also ich sehe drei Optionen. Jetzt habe ich den dort anwesenden Herren auch gesagt. Erstens, ähm das nutzt keiner,
und das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch die beste Option für alle Beteiligten, weil ähm RCS kostet die Anwender dann kein Geld. Die Server werden nicht angegriffen und ähm ja, keiner hat großen Schaden, wenn sie mal aufgemacht werden.
Zweite Option ist, die ich für weniger wahrscheinlich halte, das setzt sich durch, dann wird das da früher oder später krachen, weil einer die Büchsen aufmacht,
Und dritte Option wäre eben, sie nutzen's jetzt noch, äh nutzen jetzt noch die Gelegenheit, das Demel-Gesetz so zu ändern, dass sie eine vernünftige Ende zu Endeverschlüssung drin haben,
und dann hätten sie wirklich für ihren E-Government-Traum da durchaus eine eine solide Basis, ne. Ähm.
Aber ich glaube, da schlägt ein tiefes Gesetz von der Endkompetenz der Mächtigen zu,
Also am Ende ist es halt irgendwie genau das Problem, was wir überall an verschiedenen Bereichen haben, dass ähm,
Wann immer sie mal so eine halbwegs gute Idee haben, wie zum Beispiel halt, ich will eigentlich ja gerne tatsächlich mit meinem Start per E-Mail kommunizieren können, dass der mir dauernd irgendwie dieses Papier in den Briefkasten schickt, was ich dann irgendwie scannen, Archivieren, wiederfinden, nach zehn Jahren nochmal aus dem weichen Tor ziehen muss,
Finde ich ja hochgradig lästig. Also ich will ja eigentlich tatsächlich mit meinem Start per E-Mail kommunizieren. Ich fände sehr gut, wenn die sich tun würden. Nur ist halt das Problem dabei.
Auch gar nicht mal, ich weiß gar nicht, warum man sich auf E-Mail so so festlegt. Ich fände.
Digital kommunizieren. Also.
Habe ja gar nichts gegen diese Webinterfaces, wenn sie nicht die ganze Zeit mit ja war äh Plug-in,
überhaupt darstellt, funktioniert.
Er sieht fast, ich würde halt einfach gerne tatsächlich mit meinem Start irgendwie in die digitale Art und Weise kommunizieren, ob's jetzt E-Mail ist oder was auch immer, äh sei mal dahingestellt,
Das Problem dabei ist halt nur, wie wir bei diesem, die E-Mail-Gesetz wieder mal sehen,
Wann immer die so eine halbwegs gute Idee haben, so oder die zumindest im Ansatz irgendwie ganz früh mal irgendwann so ansatzweise gut war,
mutiert die halt über die diese Lobbyveranstaltung und den den Einfluss der Sicherheitsbehörden, die dann immer gerne mitlesen wollen,
dahin, dass es halt irgendwie so ein schrecklicher Unsinn, wie die Emil wird,
sind halt so genau diese beiden Aspekte. Zum einen die Sicherheitsbörse sagen, wir wollen aber abhören können oder wir wollen zu der Erweiterung unserer Befugnis benutzen können. Und zum anderen haben wir dann halt irgendwie so Bitcom und ähnliche Konsorten, die halt,
Da irgendwie noch eine Möglichkeit sind, halt noch mal so ein paar wie Bundeseuros abzufassen für Förderung oder sonstige äh äh Geldverdienerei. Und deswegen diese eigentlich möglicherweise
Im Ansatz haben wir ganz guten Ideen und Gesetze, nämlich zum Beispiel sowas wie dann halt immer zu so einem Kram mutieren. Und deswegen sage ich immer, wir brauchen für solche Sachen halt einfach
nicht-staatliche Strukturen. So, wir brauchen so was wie zum Beispiel halt ähm,
Der Grundgedanke des öffentlich-rechtlichen, nämlich eine nichtstaatliche Struktur, die aber der Öffentlichkeit dient,
Also zum Früh jetzt nicht so was wie die GZ da wieder bauen, sondern einfach sagen, wir brauchen eine Struktur, die halt.
Vielleicht sowas wie so eine Internet-ARD.
Genau, also sowas, was halt einfach sozusagen sich darum kümmert, dass bestimmte Infrastrukturen,
funktionieren da sind und irgendwie, also wie zum Beispiel halt so 'ne Zertifikatsinfrastruktur, wie Kommunikationsinfrastruktur für man kann mit seinen Behörden kommunizieren
so und die eben nicht von den Sicherheitsbehörden irgendwie dominiert wird und die eben nicht von den Profitinteressen irgendwie der der Internetkonzern dominiert wird,
Damit wir uns allen am besten gedient, weil offensichtlich ist diesen, die jetzigen Strukturen nicht dazu in der Lage, sowas entgift.
Ähm hm.
Meinst du das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik?
Nee, die sind ja eine nachgeordnete Behörde des Innenministeriums, insofern fallen sie ganz klar unter Start.
Aber so etwas wie die Aufgabe, die das BSI wahrnimmt, so einer Rolle zum.
BSI müsste eigentlich zum Beispiel eine völlig unabhängige Behörde werden, die halt also kein Ministerium untersteht. Und genauso hätte ich eigentlich gerne eine
Bundeskommunikationsagentur, die halt sich darum kümmert, halt irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass ich mit meinen Behörden digital kommunizieren kann
die nicht irgendwie in dem Innenministerium untersteht und die nicht dem Wirtschaftsministerium untersteht und die nicht irgendwie eine Partnerschaft mit The Systems und irgendwie diesen ganzen anderen Leuten hat, sondern einfach irgendwie nur dafür sorgt, dass meine Interessen als Bürger im digitalen Raum neutral und so umgesetzt werden, dass es halt irgendwie,
vernünftig ist.
Ja, finde ich sehr nachvollziehbare Forderung.
Na ja, also mit der E-Mail findet das aber nicht statt. Äh jetzt war das im Innenausschuss. Das heißt, auch da rollt jetzt wieder irgendeine Gesetzeslage heran, die dann alle ganz toll finden, weil sind ja bald Wahlen. Wir müssen ja fertig werden.
Das da ist jetzt mit wenig äh mit wenig Diskussionswissen, ja. Nein, das ist ja auch.
Zu rechnen, weil es interessiert mal wieder keinen Schwanz, aber ich glaube die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Option eins äh eintritt, dass es keiner benutzt, die ist wahrscheinlich eh maximal groß, oder?
Die halte ich für maximal groß, auf jeden Fall.
allerdings, was äh Fun fact, war meine Freundin genau am gleichen Tag, also im Moment zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich in der Anhörung war, war sie irgendwie beim Bürgeramt, weil sie ihren Führerschein verloren hatte und musste irgendwie den neue Bahn tragen
Ähm oder eine Neuausstellung. Und die war drei Stunden da beschäftigt, ne? Und ähm oder oder zwei. Und die sagte, das wäre jetzt schon durchaus schön gewesen,
ne, wenn man das jetzt mal per äh E-Mail oder D-Mail hätte machen können. Und ähm.
Was hätte machen können?
Einfach sagen, ich habe meinen Führerschein verloren, schickt mir einen Führerschein.
Neuen Herr, zack, bumm, hier.
Hier ist mein Zertifie ist mein Zertifikat irgendwie, meine Daten habt ihr noch, schickt mir den Scheiß. Warum geht das nicht? Zweitausenddreizehn? Warum muss ich für meine Lohnsteuerkarte oder wie auch immer das Ding da heißt, irgendwie zum Amt laufen? Wieso muss ich für eine Meldebestätigung da hinlaufen? Herr Gott.
Außerdem bin ich umgezogen, wollte noch ein Gewerbe anmelden. Ja, vielen Dank, schickt darüber, ne, per D-Mail, ja, also.
Ja, also ich meine, bei so Ausweissachen, da wäre ich noch generell sehr vorsichtig, aber zumindest die Sachen, die jetzt auch nicht so mega sicherheitsrelevant sind, äh in zunehmendem Maße, zumindest so das, was das Bürgeramt
Also die die Eulen, die die normalen Sachen mit gib mir doch mal eine Bescheinigung, gib mir doch mal eine Meldebestätigung. Sowas zum Beispiel, ne
dass äh ja, das wäre in der Tat wünschenswert. Wir äh schauen mal vielleicht muss da auch äh die Netzgemeinde mit guten Ideen voran äh schreiten. Schauen wir mal,
was sich da äh ergibt.
Ist noch ein ein gefallenes Mädchen. Als Rätsel gebe ich das den Hörern mit. Und zwar sagte der ähm Herr Doktor Roleder ähm,
vom Bitcom dann so als er als er wusste es war fünf vor zwei oder was und ich komme nicht mehr dran, hat er gesagt, ja äh,
Man muss bei sowas immer eine Abwägung machen zwischen IT-Sicherheit und Datenschutz und bei der D-Mail haben wir ganz klar den Fokus auf den Datenschutz gelegt,
Ich war ich bin da bis heute drüber am Rätsel, was er damit sagt,
Ich kann es, ich verstehe es nicht, ja. Ich weiß.
Ach so, ich weiß warum. Ähm Datenschutz ist natürlich Antivirus. Weil der Virus will an deine Daten.
Und davor schützt sie.
IT-Sicherheit ist diese andere mit der Verschlüsselung. Dieses schwierige mit der Matte und so. Was die Menschen nicht verstehen, weswegen weil sie da eine Zusatzsoftware für brauchen.
Befriedigt mich nicht. Dieser diese Erklärung befriedigt mich.
Ist ja auch nur eine Theorie. Ich ich glaube, er hat halt einfach nur.
Ich glaube, er hat halt einfach nur gedacht, das ist ein geiler Satz, den versteht keiner. Dann denken dann denken alle so, hoa, mein weißer Mann, überzeugend, Datenschutz ist wichtig.
Ja, ich glaube auch die Reden. Ja, die reden, die reden einfach nur. Datenschutz ist wichtig. Er ist so ein bisschen wie die Loriot Bundestagsrede.
Hm, ja, so kommt man sich da manchmal wirklich vor.
Ich habe mich da echt.
Muss man auch mit Nachdruck äh sagen und ich betone, dass äh noch ein weiteres Mal ausdrücklich und äh ich denke, dass wir jetzt auch weitermachen können.
Wir werden und wir werden eine gemeinsame Lösung finden.
Und das ist auf jeden.
Ist auch gut für alle.
Es ist jetzt schon neunundneunzig Prozent sicher. Das hat er auch gesagt. Ja, bei achtzig Millionen Bürgern macht.
Kein Problem.
Super.
Naja gut, ja, also wir haben ja auch äh nichts ähm zu befürchten, denn wir haben ja alle Breitbandinternet in Zukunft, da wird das schon irgendwie mit der Kommunikation, mit dem Staat schon äh klappen.
Ist auch vorbei.
Ja, mich erreicht ihr ja, da kann ich ja jetzt auch mal berichten, mich erreicht ihr ja leider im Urlaub so ein bisschen en passant,
Äh auch diese Mail, die dann schnell äh Verbreitung fand, weil sie nicht nur mich erreichte, sondern auch noch äh andere. Breaking News war's dann bei den äh Fanboys, die äh die Zeit hatten da mal eine passende Webseite zusammenzustellen,
Und ja, in dieser Mail waren doch sehr ähm belastbare Informationen, äh dass die Telekom halt jetzt plant.
die teilweise oder überhaupt generell schon in den Verträgen vorgesehene Volumendrossel dann auch wahr zu machen allerdings noch in etwas verschärfterer Form als das derzeit in diesen Verträgen drin steht,
und ja äh ich habe jetzt die Zahlen gerade nicht äh vor mir, aber,
äh die Kernessenz ist, dass so sehr fragwürdige Datenmengen grenzen dort aufgerufen werden für normale DSL äh Anschlüsse waren's glaube ich fünfundsiebzig Gigabyte, für VDSL dann noch immerhin zweihundert Gigabyte.
Und äh wenn man dann halt dieses Limit durchbricht und was ich mich an der Stelle schon mal frage, ist von welcher Richtung reden sie jetzt, ja, also,
reicht zweihundert also geht's nur um Runterladen oder geht's um hochladen oder wird das auch noch beides gerechnet, also das kann ich hundert runter und hundert hoch und dann bin ich,
zweihundert Kilo, also das habe ich da das ist vollkommen unklar, so wie man ja auch auf Verträgen äh und nirgendswo die Information findet, wie viel Upload man eigentlich hat,
auch immer, also dann soll's irgendwie klick machen und dann äh ist man so auf ähm dreihundertvierundachtzig Kilobit, was eine interessante Zahl ist, weil es handelt sich ja dabei sozusagen um den Native Speed von dem ersten 3G UMTS.
Ah, ich dachte, ich hätte mich gewundert, wo sie an die Zahl kam.
Ist auch der nette Speed von von dem einen mega bit äh DSL ab.
Ja, stimmt, genau. Das war der.
Drei vierundachtzig ab.
Bei dem einen Megabit A. Mhm.
Ja genau, also so eine Zahl, die man immer mal wieder sieht und ja, das soll dann sozusagen, also ich meine, diese dreihundertvierundachtzig Kilo beziehen sich ja dann wahrscheinlich auf den
Downstream, Frage ist halt dann auch wieder, was ist mit dem Upstream, wenn der dann sozusagen
in demselben Maße, äh in dem selben Maße reduziert wird, also wenn ich jetzt mal von den fünfzig Megabit auf dreihundertvierundachtzig Kilobit runterrechne, dann kann irgendwie von dem Upstream ja auch nicht mehr so sehr viel äh übrig bleiben.
Zwei Kilobitt oder drei.
Ja, also es ist wirklich klar, natürlich, ne? Röhrchen.
Für die SSH reicht's aber doch, ne? Ist halt so.
Ja, sie können auch noch chatten. Ja.
Also der Hintergrund dabei ist halt, dass die Telekom äh sind ja zwei Sachen. Zum einen hat die Telekom äh also wenn man sich so an diese fünfundsiebzig Gigabyte anguckt, so sind halt sowas wie drei Blu-ray Filme, ne, also halt so über den Daumen,
Du sollst ja deine Filme halt auch nicht irgendwie aus dem holen, sondern halt aus ihrem irgendwiees Angebot. Ähm das ist das eine und zum anderen,
haben die halt einfach kein Bock ihre ihre auszubauen ne? Die wollen halt einfach,
sozusagen mit dem, was jetzt da an stehen haben, halten noch auf absehbare Zeit halt irgendwie ordentlich Geld verdienen und im Zweifel verkaufen sie dann halt für optionale zwanzig Euro halt noch die nächsten zweihundert Gigabyte.
Gut, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, ähm,
Was kann jetzt eigentlich passieren? Dann gehen wir mal davon aus, die Telekom macht das und führt das einfach so ein, dann ist es ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt alle gleich zu äh zum Mitbewerber wechseln, weil wir wissen ja alle, zum Mitbewerber wechseln ist heutzutage keine Option, weil's meistens gar keine gibt
schon gar nicht bei Highspeed-Anschlüssen.
Und es würde auch nicht wundern, wenn die Mitbewerber das längst schon auch mit Wüsten.
Beziehungsweise gleich so gleich.
Reimen sich dann die Hände und sagen, ah, super, mal wieder mehr Geld verdienen und so weiter, auch kein Problem. Was ich auch sehr vermisse in diesen Geschichten äh ist halt auch so klare Aussagen dadrüber, ähm,
wie man denn das dann sozusagen wieder aufgelöst
kommt, weil ich meine, was soll das dann heißen, dass ich dann bis zum Ende des Monats schleichend unterwegs sein soll? Kann man überhaupt mehr bezahlen? Wird's einen Tarif geben, der das äh alles äh abdeckt? Also das ist auch ähm,
Ein äh echtes äh Problem.
Na ja, ich meine, am Ende ist halt irgendwie die Frage, wenn äh,
welche äh welche Anschlüsse sie am Ende liefern können, ne, sie waren diese diese Fibertouranschlüsse, die sie ja gerne haben wollen, ähm wie heißt denn diese Entertainment Fiber? Ist auch geil, ne?
Habe ich noch nie gehört vorher, muss ich sagen.
Das ist halt irgendwie deren deren Versuche halt irgendwie halt irgendwie den äh,
Na ja, nee, ist nicht Opal, ist halt irgendwie den der Nachfolger. Nee, der Nachfolger zwischendurch hat mal wieder Kupfer. Ähm,
Und da wollen sie dann halt natürlich irgendwie ihr eigenes Videotraining halt reintun, ne? Das ist halt so der.
Ja, also die die diese Planung geht äh bis vierhundert Gigabyte hoch bei diesen dicken Fiber zweihundert Anschlüssen, von denen ich mich echt frage, wo man die eigentlich kriegt, ne?
Na, die gibt's noch nicht. Die bieten sie noch nicht an.
Und das ist auch geil, erinnerst du dich, du erinnerst dich bestimmt noch da dran, diese uralte Grafik, die man mal ausgegraben hat und die stand, glaube ich, in der Datenschleuder. Telekom, Multimediaplanung oder so eine,
Grafik war mit irgendwie so dicke Leitung rein ins Haus und dünne Leitung raus, so wie.
Nee, ja, genau.
X Seiten und da war dann irgendwie so ein Button irgendwie beim Userterminal nämlich kaufen.
Mhm. Genau.
Und genauso ist hier so die diese Vision, diese Visualisierung des äh Highspeed-Volumens, wie sie das nennen, ja? Highspeed-Volumen ist auch geil, ja, also seit wann ist ein Volumen schnell? Also
äh ja und das wird dann hier einfach in Filmen pro Woche oder auch HD Filmen pro Woche.
Stunden online Gaming pro Tag oder Downloads.
Oder wie viele Fotos in hoher Qualität.
So einfach so richtig schlimmer Marketing Bullshit.
Ja, ja, also man kann zehn Stunden Webradio pro Tag.
Na das ist halt das dann, was der Typ oder die Typen im T-Punkt. Ne? Also, wenn sie, da können sie zehn Stunden am Tag Webradio hören, da ist das immer noch nicht aufgebraucht. So viel ist das.
Kannst du zwei Stunden Radio hören, drei Filme im Monat ausleihen in HD, zehn äh pro Monat. Außerdem noch vierhundert Fotos hoch oder runterladen
bisschen äh Online-Gaming, das geht sogar länger als Radio, ne, wer hätt's gedacht, ja, kannst noch fünfzig Programme runterladen
zweihundert Musik runterladen und tausend Webseiten auf Hunde, sagt sich doch jeder. Mehr brauche ich doch nicht.
Tausend Webseiten.
Ja, also das ist.
Viele kenne ich gar nicht.
Ich finde das, ich finde das wirklich, also ich finde das schon perfide ist, irgendwie das einzige, was mir da äh einfällt. Das ist also wirklich eine Verarschung. Äh,
ohne Ende und ich weiß bloß ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig äh was da eigentlich gegen helfen soll.
Was dagegen helfen würde, wäre, wenn irgendwie die Bundesnetzagentur da als Regulierer eingreift, was nämlich ihre Aufgabe ist,
insbesondere in in Ecken, wo es halt irgendwie ein Monopolanbieter ist, wie die Telekom, muss die Bundesnetzagentur halt eigentlich da einschreiten. Sie tut's halt nur nicht, weil der Bund immer noch einen signifikanten Anteil von Telekom-Aktien hält.
dementsprechend da den auch wieder unzulässige Interessensvermischung da ist und also das Problem, was was wir jetzt hier sehen bei dieser Telekom ist halt, die wollten ja eigentlich,
einen äh quasi eine Regulierung erreichen, dass sie sagen, wenn sie Fasern nach Hause legen, also die sie hier entertainen mit Fiber und so, dass sie die dann.
Ähm eine Weile exklusiv nutzen können, also dass sie halt äh da keine äh anderen Anbieter mehr drauflassen wollen. Und da hat der Bund gesagt, so nee,
so machen wir mal nicht. So, also ist halt nicht nicht irgendwie der äh,
ja entspricht nicht so ganz dem, was wir wollen. Und dann sagt die Telekom, na gut, okay, dann gibt's bei uns keinen Business Case,
also ist unsere Aufgabe jetzt zu merken was wir haben,
Dass also irgendwie Fiber to the Home Ausbau halt so langsam wie's irgendwie geht und ansonsten halt irgendwie den äh ja, zu merken, was halt da ist und das ist halt wieder genauso ein Problem, das eigentlich ist ist so Telekommunikation. Der Internetanschluss ist halt eigentlich sowas wie Strom,
Ist halt eigentlich ein Stromnetz. So einfach nicht. Ich werde da irgendwie äh drum rum diskutieren, warum muss das irgendwie eine Struktur sein, mit der jemand irgendwie große Profite machen?
eigentlich wollen wir irgendwie eine Struktur haben, die sagt, okay, äh wir bringen dir die größtmöglich technischen, mögliche Bandbreite nach Hause zu geringstmöglichen Kosten,
weil's halt eben mittlerweile auch Aufgabe des Staates sein sollte, dafür zu sorgen, dass halt irgendwie Strukturen da sind, die uns irgendwie mit Kommunikation versorgen,
So und dazu gehört halt zum Beispiel eine garantierte Mindestbandbreite, ne, was wir auch gefordert haben als Club,
Gesagt haben so, egal was passiert. Du willst halt irgendwie immerhin mindestens einen Megabizime auf jeden Anschluss haben, der halt nicht mit irgendwelchem Traffic-Shaping äh DPI oder was auch immer genau dieses Jahr müssen's wahrscheinlich dann schon zwei sein.
Ich habe schon immer zwei gesagt.
Vier.
Ich habe vor zehn Jahren schon gesagt, zwei.
Irgendwas was halt.
Wurde ich mal gefragt, ich war mal echt mal wirklich so vor vor ich glaub es ist schon fast zehn Jahre gab's mal so 'ne Veranstaltung ja wo so allerlei kluge Leute irgendwie rumsaßen und ich dann so auf dem Podium meinte so ja wir brauchen einfach mal zwei Megabitter,
Was meinen sie denn damit machen? Und so, ja, weißt du, so ja, was weiß ich, wie wär's mit Backups so?
Warten. Ja, ne, vor allen Dingen ist die Antwort einfach nicht warten.
So und heute ist das tatsächlich auch ein Argument. Ich meine, reden hier alle irgendwie die deutsche Cloud und so weiter. Das muss jetzt hier irgendwie alles werden und so, ne? Willst du deine Daten sichern? Und dann kannst du deine Daten nicht sichern, weil du irgendwie eine Drossel äh,
Das geht einfach alles gar nicht. Also wenn schon, also ich meine, ich sage mal, ich kann generell verstehen, dass wenn ich jetzt so einen hundert Megabit,
zwanzig, also hundert Megabit Down, zwanzig Megabit Up VDSL einhundert, was es nicht gibt, aber was es mal geben müsste,
Ja, wenn's den Anschluss habe. Und ich da wirklich jetzt Software fahre, die wirklich zu vierundzwanzig Stunden das Ding irgendwie zu fünfzig Prozent auslastet,
dann da dann haben hätten die ein Problem, wenn das viele Leute machen,
ja? Ist ja auch so, auf der einen Seite wird immer von Mischkalkulationen gesprochen, auf der anderen Seite ist das immer total böse, wenn einige das dann ausnutzen,
Ja, also was denn jetzt? Mischkalkulation, ja, oder, oder, oder böse Wichte, die jetzt unbedingt mit einer Drossel bekämpft werden müssen. Ähm
das aber ich stimmen dir zu Frank, es ist halt vor allem im Wesentlichen ein Problem des Auftrages, ja? Es wird immer viel erzählt von einundzwanzigsten Jahrhundert und digitale Gesellschaft und der Aufbruch und die Wirtschaftsförderung, aber es gibt irgendwie keinerlei Linie
in der man klar gesagt wird, so äh so eine Sachen behindern einfach den Fortschritt äh äh im Land und das geht einfach nicht.
Die Sache ist ja, warum wollen sie's machen? Also, dass ja die die bisher noch ungeklärte Frage. Klar, sie wollen,
sie wollen nicht, sie wollen nicht weiter investieren, sondern lieber erstmal weiter melken. Andererseits öffnen sie sich dadurch ja auch dann genau wie im,
wie sie's schon im Mobilbereich machen, wahrscheinlich äh mit ihrer, wir hatten das ja hier lang und breit kritisiert, diese Spotify-Flatrate, dass die Möglichkeit, das zu tun, sichern sie sich ja dann auch im Festnetzbereich,
sie sagen, wir haben jetzt die Volumenbeschränkung, dadurch können wir dann auch irgendwie so ein, so ein, so ein, ja, ich sage mal, so ein, so einen Pöbeltarif anbieten, der irgendwie äh tatsächlich das bietet, was normaler Nutzer erstmal
oder was diese Nutzer eben nicht überschreiten werden. Da gibt's irgendwie ein paar Leute, die sind da regelmäßig an der Grenze, die haben am am Ende des Monats ihr Inklusiv Volumen
gebraucht. Die haben dann entweder die Wahl ihren äh noch ein paar Tage zu warten, bis wieder neuen neuen Monat gibt. Oder ähm
Sie kaufen dann doch mal den teureren Tarif, aber das Schöne ist ja dann zu sagen, ey, wisst ihr was und hier so,
euer Facebook Traffic, der geht ja schon mal nicht von ab. Und euer Spotify auch nicht. Da müsst ihr, könnt ihr euch hier so eine, so eine äh Zusatzdienstleistung kaufen und so weiter. Und das ist der der richtig schöne erste Schritt,
dahin, dass alle auf einmal Netzneutralitätsverletzende Angebote haben wollen.
Klar. Tja.
Und das ist äh wirklich.
Denke, dass was man also falls wir eine Partei hätten, die sich um sowas kümmert, wäre es natürlich ein schönes Wahlkampfthema, ne?
Aber haben wir ja leider nicht.
Was uns eigentlich dann zum.
Thema und letzten Thema bringt.
Ja, in Anbetracht der der sehr also ist ja jetzt durchaus so die mittidepressivste Sendung, die wir bisher hatten, was so die Themen.
Aber nicht ohne Unterhaltungsfall.
Sie hatte durchaus Unterhaltungsfaktor, aber wir hatten selten eine solche äh also wie die Zeit so
vorangedacht. Ich ach krass, nächste Sendung, übles Thema. Oh, wir wir brauchen Frank. So, dann ähm.
Ich habe verschließlich einen Ruf zu verlieren, nicht wahr?
Nein, also.
Was ich zu diesen ganzen Themen dann noch äh ergab, war dann eine Debatte darüber, dass äh die die Netzgemeinde jetzt äh verkackt hat, ja. Also wir hatten das eingangs schon erwähnt, ähm,
und alle.
Villingen hat es uns prophezeit.
Wer hat das prophezeit? Ja genau, genau. Der hat ja.
Hilfe legen, hieß er doch, ne? Ja, genau, genau, der hat Netzgemeinde, ihr werdet den Kampf verlieren.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass der olle Hebeling, ja? So, also es gibt eine lange Kritik. Es gibt ähm,
Es gibt Kritik an den an der Piratenpartei, es gibt die Piratenpartei jetzt irgendwie auf ihrer Webseite so eine Artikelserie veröffentlicht. Äh was tut die Piratenpartei eigentlich gegen dieses und dieses und dieses, um irgendwie zu betonen, dass sie ja durchaus Arbeit leisten.
woraufhin politisch, inkorrekt, aber inhaltlich korrekt,
äußerte, dass die Putzfrau auch keiner fragt, wie lange sie gebraucht hat, um den Fleck nicht wegzuputzen,
Und ähm entsprechend ging es dann weiter und jeder zeigt auf jeden und schrie ihn an. Und ähm die Netzgemeinde äh ist jetzt ist schlecht und allen fühlt es fehlt es an Geld und wir haben's alles falsch gemacht.
Ach, na, es fehlt uns alles nicht an Geld. Das ist also ich denke schon, dass eines der Probleme tatsächlich wirklich die Piraten sind, weil die Energie, die die da verbraten haben, mit sich gegenseitig runterputzen und irgendwie über irgendwelchen Scheißstreiten und irgendwie es immer noch nicht hinbekommen, irgendwie sowas wie irgendwie ein,
Internetwerkzeuge für irgendwie politische Willensbildung in ihrer Partei zu benutzen,
also man stelle sich nun mal vor, diese Energie und diese Menge Leute, die sich da irgendwie aufgeraucht haben irgendwie bei dem Versuch irgendwie äh ein überholtes Modell politischer Beteiligung zu replizieren
wäre tatsächlich irgendwie in richtige, inhaltliche Arbeit geflossen. Denn wenn du heute ganz woanders,
So und äh das denke ich auch mal eine Kritik, die man auch einfach mal anbringen muss, dass man sagen muss, okay, also das äh die,
ähm bei allem, was irgendwie die Piraten getan haben dafür, dass diese Themen irgendwie in Deutschland irgendwie auf die Agenda gekommen sind, beziehungsweise halt eben äh wichtiger genommen wurden aus Angst davor, dass halt möglicherweise,
Piratenpartei den etablierten Parteien halt irgendwie stimmen klaut.
Ähm ist es halt eben doch, gilt auch genau das Umgekehrte, der genau der Umgekehrte Effekt, jetzt ist diese Angst halt weg. Also ist halt irgendwie so, dass irgendwie die,
die Furcht davor, dass äh dass diese Themen äh viele Stimmen kosten könnten, ist halt nicht mehr da, zumindest nicht irgendwie so, weil wie die CDU CSU und FDP,
und dementsprechend benehmen die sich halt dann einfach natürlich so wie sie immer getan haben, nämlich zu sagen so, OK, wir wissen, dass wir irgendwie nicht recht haben, aber ist uns doch egal, machen wir halt,
So und ich denke, das soll so ein Punkt, wo man.
Also ich habe ja auch immer auf Twitter irgendwie den den großen Spaß mit denen also es gibt da so eine Standardantwort von den Piraten lautet ja hey, dann komm doch zu uns und mach's besser.
Ne, also mach doch irgendwie so also komm doch, also mach doch mal irgendwie besser bei uns hier so irgendwie hier kannst du mitmachen. Und weißt du, woran mich das erinnert?
politisch völlig unkorrekt, ob ich dafür mal, ne? Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an DDR,
Wenn man Dach, wenn man da irgendwie gesagt hat, man will ja irgendwie ein bisschen mal was am System hat, die SED sagt, hey komm zu uns, wir sind zwar das System, aber hier kannst du wirklich was ändern.
Jetzt sind wir ja kurz vorm Nazivergleich. Der Stasi-Vergleich.
Also deswegen liebe Pira, liebe Piraten würde kritisiert werdet, dann benutzt doch bitte nicht dieses doofe, komm doch zu uns, hier kannst du's besser machen, Argument, man kann's bei euch nicht besser machen.
Für dieses Argument scheinen die Piraten anfällig zu sein, weil sie haben ja immer eine Partei gegründet, also das das ist ja das das Angebot, was das System an dich macht, ja also.
Zum Gründe noch eine Partei. Ich meine, Herr Gott, man kann sich da, wie gesagt, okay, auch beliebig dran aufheizen irgendwie und irgendwie viel Zeit damit verbringen, Wahlkämpfe zu an, diese ganzen Kram zu machen, aber.
Ja gut, ich meine, es gibt ja jetzt auch Stimmen, die so ein bisschen die äh äh Glas-Halb voll, halbleer äh Metapher bemühen und sagen, na ja, man kann ja auch, äh man muss nicht immer so ganz digital äh und
binär nach dem äh Endergebnis, Gesetz ist durchgekommen, Gesetz ist nicht durchgekommen, sondern man sollte vielleicht auch mal schauen, was ist denn durchgekommen, also äh Herr Stadler hat ja dann seinen Blogeintrag,
ganz andere Perspektive eingenommen und meint so, im Wesentlichen, naja, okay, es gibt zwar jetzt etwas, das Leistungsschutzrecht heißt, und beschlossen ist, aber im Vergleich zu dem, was es ursprünglich mal,
werden sollte, also womit die Lobby tatsächlich mal angekommen ist, mit Wasser doch eine tolle Idee wäre, dass davon ja relativ wenig übrig geblieben sei. So, dass man sozusagen schon auch einen Widerstand,
darstellt und dieser Sichtweise kann ich auch durchaus was abgewinnen.
Ich weine aber nicht über das Leistungsrecht. Ich weine viel mehr über äh Bestandsdatenausguck.
Ja eher gut, was es jetzt auch immer ist, ja? Also ich meine, ich glaube, Sascha Lobus, Artikel ging auch im Wesentlichen übers Leistungsschutzrecht,
ja? Wir haben jetzt hier nochmal eine andere Perspektive und definitiv dieses Bestandsdaten äh Gesetz. Das ist äh das Auskunftsgesetz. Das ist,
so dermaßen unter dem Radar und da muss man wahrscheinlich auch eher mal darüber Gedanken machen, inwiefern die äh Frühwarnsysteme verbessert werden können. Also gerade die Arbeit in den Ausschüssen wird,
in der Regel zu wenig beobachtet.
Na, zumal.
Da haben wir aber auch mit unseren äh Transparenzsystemen, die wir hier auch schon häufiger vorgestellt haben, hier so trägt, et cetera. Ja, sind ja auch schon Ansätze äh geschaffen worden, ebenso. Ich äh früh war Systeme vielleicht auch.
Wirklichkeit werden zu lassen.
Na, das Problem ist, denke ich mal, dass der
Also wir haben wir haben halt ein paar ganz grundsätzliche Probleme als uns politische Aktivisten. Ähm eines der Probleme, was ganz klar ist, ist das die Vielzahl der Themen, um die wir denken, uns kümmern zu müssen, brutal zunimmt.
da fallen halt einfach mal Sachen unter den Tisch oder die sehen wir nicht, die sind wir nicht kommen spezifisch, wenn sie aus Europa kommen
äh die ihr fast wirklich in der Bedeutung, da sind die Kontakte, die wir in den Parteien haben, auch zu naiv und nehmen nicht an, dass es durchgeht, was wie's dann plötzlich durchgeht, zum Beispiel beim Bestandsdatengesetz,
ähm und es sind halt einfach die die Vielzahl der Themen nimmt einfach zu, weil einfach alles digital wird. Also alles, was irgendwie an an Politik,
passiert, hat irgendeine Art von digitalen Aspekt und sei es auch nur ein doofes Webportal für irgendwie sowas wie das Betreuungsgeld.
So und daraus folgt eben aber auch dann, dass der also die Frage, worauf konzentrieren wir uns denn,
Was sind denn die Themen, um die wir uns wirklich kümmern und welche Themenfelder wir halt wirklich beackern wollen, äh wird halt eine entscheidende, weil unsere Bandbreite ist halt nun mal geringer als die auf der anderen Seite,
wir können halt einfach nicht mehr alles tun und so und äh das das halt, denke ich mal, auch eine Erkenntnis, die wir die wir auch umsetzen müssen, eben auch
Für mich zum Beispiel aus der Erkenntnis aus diesem Leistungsschutzrecht heraus, dass das möglicherweise halt einfach so ein Ding war, wo zu viele Leute zu viel Energie reingesteckt haben und dabei halt andere Sachen halt haben, fallen lassen, die möglicherweise wichtiger gewesen wären.
Ja, das sicherlich auch. Hm.
So und ich denke, wir müssen halt auch anfangen, das das wäre irgendwie äh die Piraten mittlerweile als irgendwie eher als Fundus von irgendwie guten Personal betrachten, denn als irgendwie Lösung, ja.
Ich, also,
es gibt ja diesen schönen Metronout Text vor John Fäbel, den wir gleich auch noch hören werden, in dem äh er sagt, man dürfe jetzt die
Piraten nicht mit dem netzpolitischen keins mal versehen, sondern man müsse die da rausholen. Und die vernünftige Initiativen ähm.
Vernünftigen Leute.
Ja, die vernünftigen Leute da rausholen. Äh,
die die ausweiten, ja, also hat dann natürlich auch äh gut für offenen Sack bekommen von einigen Leuten in den Kommentaren.
Ja, das steht ja schon länger in der Debatte. Tarifreit und der Forg. Ja.
Ja, ich meine, im Kern ist halt das Problem, eine Piraten, dass es eigentlich zwei Parteien sind, so. Ne, also ist halt irgendwie während die Grünen bei irgendwie damals in also in dem ungefähr demselben äh Zeitpunkt ihrer Geschichte,
Plus Internetierung, also Beschleunigung äh halt den Streit zwischen den Reales und den hatten, wo es halt im Wesentlichen um den Weg zu einem
einigermaßen gleichen Ziel ging,
halt eigentlich nur es darum ging setzen wir eher radikalere Politik als Forderung oder setzen wir eher bisschen irgendwie Kompromissbereiter Politik als Forderung einmal im Kern, weil man sich über das Ziel, nämlich einen ökologischen Umbau der Gesellschaft immer noch einig.
Bei den Piraten ist aber die Situation gerade, das ist halt eine linksliberale Bürgerrechtspartei
und eine eher rechtsliberal konservative FDP Ersatzpartei in ein, in einer Organisation ist
und wenn die sich halt entscheiden und sagen, wir wollen das eine oder das andere, dann ist der verbliebene Splitter Teil zu klein, um noch irgendwie relevant zu sein, das ist kein Problem, der Piraten, ich sehe auch nicht, wie es gelöst werden kann.
Fragt mich das auch, welcher von diesen beiden Teilen am Ende Piraten heißen wird.
Mhm. Ich ich weiß es nicht. Also ich.
Ich weiß es auch nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung. Es ist auch sehr schwer äh abzusehen, wie groß eigentlich diese beiden Felder tatsächlich sind, aber das liegt auch einfach daran, dass diese ganzen Meinungsbildungsprozesse bei den Piraten halt doch gar nicht transparent genug sind.
Ähm oder viel zu transparent, ja. Also ich meine, du wirst halt überflutet mit Informationen, du kannst ja die ganzen Unsinn ja auch angucken, wenn du willst und diese Mailinglisten lesen, aber das ist halt irgendwie, na ja, äh kenne auch interessante Woche.
Ja gut, Mailing ist und das wissen wir alle, sind kein Meinungsbild.
Sind ein tolles äh ja lassen wir das. Na gut, aber ich glaube, wie John Elf Nebel hatte irgendwie tatsächlich da den.
Ja. Also ich bin ich mir fällt es schwer jetzt sonderlich ähm,
Pessimismus da zu verströmen muss ich sagen, weil am Ende äh war das jetzt alles eine schöne ähm Bootphase so, ja, wir haben so von Zensursalar bis heute, wenn man das jetzt mal so, ich weiß nicht, ob,
ob jetzt die aktuelle Ereignislage
jetzt taugt, um hier wirklich einen Block in die Zeitmarktleiste zu stecken und zu sagen, von Zensursal bis heute und ab heute ist irgendwas anders. Aber wenn man jetzt einfach mal diesen Zeitraum
betrachtet, hat sich halt überhaupt erstmal so etwas gebildet. So, ja, und hat sich jetzt bemüht,
mit bestimmten Methoden was zu erreichen. Man stellt jetzt fest, okay, funktioniert alles noch nicht so ganz so, wie wir wollen, äh muss sich verbessern.
Ich denke man kann noch man kann da auch konkrete Dinge lernen. Also man irgendwie alle noch, alle waren irgendwie noch beflügelt von dem von dem Sieg über Akta kann man irgendwie so sehen,
Rausch von Acta und meinten irgendwie, ja, jetzt haben wir es wirklich, jetzt, äh, wie bezeichnet als die stärkste Lobby im Lande und was es da alles gab. Und plötzlich stolpert man irgendwie über so einen, so ein blödes Leistungsschutzrecht und ist ähm,
ist irgendwie völlig erschüttert, ne. Ähm.
Einerseits kann man da lernen, also das Leistungsschutzrecht war auch so das erste Mal, dass irgendwie so ein Konzern da mit drin ist, mit seiner eigenen
Netzgemeinde TM Organisation, dieses Igel ja wo Google hintersaß,
kann man sich überlegen, ob man äh inwiefern man sich in solchen Sachen demnächst noch engagieren möchte. Ähm,
Man kann aber auch endlich mal einsehen und das haben meines Erachtens viele noch nicht
Ausreichend eingesehen, dass diese Acta-Proteste eben nicht von hier äh Netzgemeinde TM gemacht wurden, sondern da hat man es geschafft
sehr, sehr viel mehr Leute äh zu mobilisieren, die eben nicht jeden Tag Netzpolitik, Ork lesen, die nicht jeden Tag irgendwie den Reiseteil lesen, die nicht die Pressemitteilung des CCC ewig keinen verfolgen und die eben auch vielleicht nicht Logbuch Netzpolitik hören. So
Das sind äh da sind's einfach Leute, da da hat man es geschafft, den Funken überzubringen auf viele andere, die vielleicht jetzt von diesem Leistungsschutzrecht überhaupt nicht ähm.
Weiß ich vielleicht gar nicht den Arsch für gerunzelt haben. Und ähm vielleicht muss man sich auch mal von der von dem,
Ansatz entfernen, dass man auf einmal über für jedes netzpolitische Thema irgendwie äh sich sich hochreißen muss, ja, sondern dass man einfach mal zusieht, dass man äh auch da mal es schafft zu priorisieren und eben Leute,
abstellt in in einzelnen Themenbereichen, die sich eben darum kümmern, damit einen sowas nicht passiert, dass alle sich um so ein blödes Leistungsschutzrecht kümmern, ja, was irgendwie,
im Moment auf jeden Fall nicht der Untergang des Internets sein wird,
während der auf einmal irgendwie einem dann plötzlich so 'ne so 'ne Bestandsdatenauskunft reingrätscht. Also sowas darf
nicht passieren. Und ich hab's ja noch relativ verwundert in der, weiß nicht, vor drei Wochen gesagt so und habe gesagt, das Thema, das wird groß. Ja, damit hatte ich Unrecht, das Thema äh wurde nicht groß als Thema, sondern die Auswirkungen dieses Gesetzes, was jetzt eigentlich unmittelbar vor der Tür steht, die werden.
Es wird nochmal groß werden, weil wir uns darum kümmern müssen.
also wird irgendwie das Gesetzamt irgendwie die Durchführung angibt, also beziehungsweise auch den den Weg nach Karlsruhe halt dabei irgendwie anzuschlagen. Aber äh klar ist halt eben, dass das
genau diese Frage, welche Auswirkung hat's für wie viele Leute, wie groß ist Mobilisierungspotential? Was ist eigentlich der
der tatsächliche Impakt eines Gesetzes und wie viel,
ja, also wie viel Aufwand ist es wert und wie viel wie viel Zeit und Energie ist es wert, da müssen wir einfach besser werden, so. Das war irgendwie ganz klar.
Teint. Damit ist eigentlich alles gesagt, oder?
Im Wesentlichen. Hoffen wir mal, dass bald Frühling wird.
Dann kann man auch endlich mal wieder demonstrieren, ja.
Genau, der Winter ist schuld.
Genau, legen wir die Füße abfrieren, dann demonstrieren das schon mal irgendwie echt ein guter Ansatz.
Gut, dann können wir ja jetzt ähm das Wort an Herrn Nebel äh weiterreichen und äh sagen zum Ausklang hier nochmal weise Worte sprechen und wir sagen tschüss, oder?
Denn? Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Vielen Dank fürs Kommen, Frank.
Die Netzgemeinde ist tot, lang lebe die Netzbewegung. So, haben sich jetzt alle ausgeheult? Sind die Wunden geleckt?
Haben Sie jetzt alle ehemaligen Gardisten mit der Tatsache vertraut gemacht, dass sie nicht mehr ganz vorne sind?
alle einmal um den nächstbesten Journalisten erzählt, dass die Netzgemeinde wieder ganz da unten ist, wo sie vor sechs Jahren einmal war,
Schluss mit dem Quatsch. Die jetzige Debatte macht uns schwächer als wir sind.
de legitimiert unser Anliegen und spielt den Gegnern von Grund und Bürgerrechten in die Hände und die Oles und die und die Käses dieser Welt, die lachen sich tot über uns, denn jetzt haben sie uns da,
wo sie uns immer haben wollten. Unsere Ratlosigkeit ist ihre Freude, doch das soll nicht so bleiben,
Wir können uns aus dieser misslichen Lage nämlich selbst befreien und es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Möglichkeiten, wie wir die Netzgemeinde zu einer Netzbewegung machen können.
Erstens, die guten Leute bei den zerfallenen Piraten identifizieren. Schon jetzt kehren immer mehr Leute den Piraten den Rücken,
wenn es so weitergeht, werden es noch viel mehr tun. In den Piraten steckt aber trotz der Krise immer noch ein riesiges Potential aus Menschen, die etwas verändern wollen,
Netzbewegung muss also aufhören ehemalige Piratenmitglieder mit einem Partei politischen Kainzmahl zu versehen. Stattdessen,
fitte Leute, die gute inhaltliche Arbeit leisten und tolle Ideen haben für die außerparlamentarische Arbeit gewonnen werden. Dazu müssen wir aber diese Leute erkennen und dann ansprechen,
Zweitens.
Netzgemeinde muss sich endlich den Aktivistinnen außerhalb von Berlin eröffnen. Wer außerhalb von Berlin wohnt, hat es tendenziell schwer, sich in der Netzbewegung zu etablieren oder Netzwerke zuckt,
außerhalb von Berlin wohnt muss sich seine Aufmerksamkeit hart erbloggen oder ertwittern und kann nicht einfach beim wöchentlichen Berliner Klassentreffen mit coolen Sprüchen in das Netzwerk einsteigen,
Da draußen sind jede Menge engagierte Leute, die darauf warten, dass sie eingebunden werden, sich öffnen heißt auch die ginge es aufs Land, Aktivisten gezielter ansprechen und wir müssen Leute einladen und die Netzbewegung in der Peripherie verstärken,
Drittens, erklären und vereinfachen statt Meter,
Diskussion über den Verlust des RS-Rieders hat nur deine Filter erreicht? Oh, das Leistungsschutzrecht konntest du nicht mal deinen Freunden erklären und das Meme hat nicht die kritische Masse erreicht auf deiner Indect Demo war nur drei Leute.
Vielleicht liegt das ja auch daran, dass wir uns in Spezialthemen verlieren und diese dann nicht mal richtig erklären können. Dass die Mehrheit der Leute nicht betroffen ist oder sich nicht betroffen fühlt von diesen Themen,
und dass wir nicht an ihren Emotionen rütteln können. Was wir brauchen ist mehr Mut zu geduldigen Erklärungen und mehr Mut zu griffigen Themen.
Viertens, scheiß auf Konkurrenzen,
Die Netzgemeinde hat mit ihren eitlen Frontleuten und einer Professionalisierung von NGOs und der parteipolitischen Aufsplitterung einer Atmosphäre der Konkurrenz geschaffen,
wird um die Lorbeeren gekämpft. Wer, wann, wo, bei der letzten Aktemo die Plakate und Aufkleber aufgehängt hat oder den Generator am Lautsprecherwagen angeschlossen hat,
Die Konkurrenzdenke hat uns nicht nur misstrauisch, sondern schwach gemacht. Doch,
Was kratzt es mich eigentlich als Bürgerrechtler, ob jetzt der AK Vorrat die Giguez oder der CCC einen guten Vorschlag hat? Und warum soll ich eigentlich nicht D vierundsechzig unterstützen, wenn das Projekt stimmt? Oder Digitalcourage? Wenn die etwas Vernünftiges machen.
verbünden muss endlich wieder im Vordergrund stehen. Viertens, junge, frische Leute einbinden.
Niemand von den jungen Aktivisten hat Lust, sich mit vierzigjährigen Besserwissern herumzuschlagen, die bei jeder Gelegenheit damit prahlen, wie geil doch Twitter vor vier Jahren noch war. Dass es unbedingt das,
der Blog heißt und wie toll doch die erste dot com Blase war, als wir alle das erste Mal kicker auf Arbeit spielten und das Geld von Venture Kapitalisten verbrannten,
Und während wir dann vom Krieg erzählen überholt uns die nächste Generation mit anderen Medien und Formaten, mit anderer Sprache und neuen Umgangsformen,
Wann also gibt es endlich mal ein erstes ernst gemeintes Treffen mit dieser neuen Generation. Und wie finden wir diese überhaupt und wohl und warum hat sich noch niemand auf den Weg gemacht, diesen Nachwuchs endlich mal kennenzulernen?
mit jungen und neuen Leuten kommt auch frischer Wind. Fünftens, mehr bloggen, mehr eigene Medien,
Der Konflikt um das Leistungsschutzrecht hat gezeigt, dass wir uns nicht auf die Massenmedien zur Vermittlung unserer Themen und Argumente verlassen können.
eigene starke Medien, die gute journalistische und vor allem investigative Arbeit machen und dabei ausreichend finanziert sind, sodass ein paar Leute davon leben können. Diese Medien müssen über die Netzbewegung herauswirken können.
unterstützt also Versuche für verlagsunabhängigen Journalismus und blockt doch einfach selber auch wieder etwas mehr. Sechstens,
runter vom Schoß der Macht.
Es fing mit dem Netzpolitischen Dialog bei De Maizire an, bei dem wir auf einmal super, super, super wichtig waren. Das war vielleicht gut fürs Ego, aber letztlich auch nur
Vereinnahmsstrategie, die in einer aussichtslosen Beschäftigungstherapie für die herausragendsten Aktivisten in der Enquete-Kommission endete.
Zensursular hingegen haben wir gekippt, ohne auf dem Schoß der Macht zu sitzen und jetzt müssen wir da wieder runter.
Öffnung für Bürgerrechtsthemen aller Art. Heute nur von digitalen und Grund- und Bürgerrechten zu reden, bringt uns nicht weiter,
Bürgerrechte lassen sich kaum noch aufteilen in Netz- und Nicht-Netz. Also nur Mut zu Bündnissen mit der Friedensbewegung gegen Kampfdrohnen oder für eine Asylrecht, dass da diesen Namen verdient,
das Verbünden mit klassischen Organisationen kann die Netzbewegung nur stärken. Und weiterhin gilt natürlich,
Freiheit ist es wert, niemals zu resignieren.